ANDREW HUBERMAN: Welcome to
the Huberman Lab podcast,
where we discuss science
and science-based tools
for everyday life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Andrew Huberman,
and I'm a professor
of neurobiology
and ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Today, we are
discussing breathing.
Now, breathing is
something that we are all
familiar with because, frankly,
we are all doing it right now.
And we do it during our waking
states and while we are asleep.
And most of us have probably
heard that breathing
is essential to life.
We hear that we can survive
without food for some period
of time, maybe even
up to a month or more,
that we can't survive
that long without water,
but we could survive a
few days without water,
depending on how well hydrated
we are when we go into that
water deprivation and the heat
of the environment we happen
to be in, but that we cannot
survive without breathing
for more than a few minutes and
that if we cease to breathe,
that our brain and our
bodily tissues will die.
And, in fact, that is true.
However, despite
everybody's knowledge
that breathing is
essential to life,
I don't think that
most people realize
just how important
how we breathe
is to our quality of life.
And that includes our mental
health, our physical health,
and what we call
performance, that
is, our ability to
tap into skills,
either physical or cognitive,
in ways that we would not
be able to otherwise if we
are not breathing correctly.
So today, we are going
to talk about what
it is to breathe correctly, both
at rest, during sleep, in order
to reduce our levels of
stress, in order to wake up
or to become more
alert deliberately,
and many, many other
things, including
how to stop hiccuping.
This is one of the most searched
for topics on the internet.
Today, I will teach
you the one method that
is actually linked to science.
No, it does not involve
drinking a glass of water
backwards from the
opposite side of the cup
or holding your breath in
any kind of esoteric way.
It actually relates to the
neural mechanisms, that is,
the brain to body connections
that cause the hiccup.
Hiccup is a spasm of
that neural circuit,
and I'll teach you how to turn
off that neural circuit in one
try.
And that's not a
technique I developed.
It's a technique that's
actually been known
about for several centuries.
And we now know the
underlying mechanism.
So today's discussion
will give to you
many tools that you can apply.
All of these tools are, of
course, behavioral tools.
They're completely zero cost.
And in telling you
how those tools work,
you'll learn a lot about
how the breathing, a.k.a.
the respiratory, system,
works and how it interfaces
with the other organs
and tissues of the body,
in particular the brain.
In fact, one of the
most important things
to understand about breathing
right here at the outset
is that breathing is unique
among brain and bodily
functions in that it lies at the
interface between our conscious
and our subconscious behavior.
And it represents
a bridge literally
in the brain between the
conscious and the subconscious.
What do I mean by that?
Well, breathing does not
require that we pay attention
to our breathing
or that we are even
aware that we are breathing.
It will just carry on in the
background either normally
or abnormally,
and I'll teach you
what normal and abnormal
breathing is in a little bit.
However, breathing is unique
among brain and bodily
functions in that at any
moment, we can consciously
take control of how we breathe.
This is an absolutely
spectacular and highly unusual
feature of brain function.
For instance, your
digestion is carrying on
in the background right
now whether or not
you've had food recently or not.
But you can't simply
control your digestion
by thinking about it
in a particular way.
In fact, most people can't
even control their thinking
by trying to control
their thinking.
That actually takes
some practice.
It can be done-- a topic
for a future episode.
However, breathing is unique.
Breathing will carry on
involuntarily, subconsciously
in the background,
as I said before.
But if, at any moment, you want
to hold your breath or inhale
more deeply or vigorously or
exhale longer than you inhale,
you can do that.
Very few, if any, other neural
circuits in your brain and body
allow that level of control.
And it turns out that level
of control is not an accident.
It has been hypothesized that
by controlling breathing,
the brain is actually
attempting to control
its own state of mind.
Now, the way this was originally
stated in a scientific research
paper was a little
bit different.
It was a little
bit physiological.
The statement was, "The brain,
by regulating breathing,
controls its own excitability."
Excitability in the
context of neurobiology
is how able the brain is to
take in new information or not,
how able the brain is or not to
turn itself off to go to sleep
and to regulate its own levels
of anxiety, focus, et cetera.
If that seems a
little bit abstract,
I'll make it simple for you.
By changing your
pattern of breathing,
you can very quickly change what
your brain is capable of doing.
In fact, a little
bit later, I'll
tell you that while
you inhale, you
are far better at learning
and remembering information
than during an exhale.
And it is a very
significant difference.
Does that mean you should
only inhale and not exhale?
No, of course not.
I'll teach you how to breathe
for the sake of learning
and memory as well as
for physical performance
and a number of other things.
So hopefully I've been
able to highlight for you
the importance of breathing
not just for life,
because, yes, breathing
is essential for life,
but that the subtleties
of how we breathe,
the duration and
intensity of our inhales
and our exhales, how long we
hold our breath between inhales
and exhales, very critically
defines our state of mind
and our state of body,
what we are able to do
and what we are not able to do.
And the great news is we
can control our breathing
and, in doing so, control
our mental health, physical
health, and performance.
Before we begin, I'd
like to emphasize
that this podcast is separate
from my teaching and research
roles at Stanford.
It is, however, part
of my desire and effort
to bring zero cost to
consumer information
about science and
science-related tools
to the general public.
In keeping with
that theme, I'd like
to thank the sponsors
of today's podcast.
Our first sponsor is HVMN.
HVMN, which is a supplement
that increases ketones,
can be used in the context
of a ketogenic diet.
However, many people,
including myself,
find that increasing
blood ketones
by using a supplement
such as HVMN
can greatly improve cognitive
ability and physical output
for mental work and
for exercise even
when not on a ketogenic diet.
There's a lot of research
supporting the fact
that even if you are
consuming carbohydrates
and you are not in ketosis,
that is, you are not following
a ketogenic diet, consuming
supplements that can increase
blood ketones can
allow you to think more
clearly for cognitive work, and
physical work, for that matter,
perform at greater output for
things like resistance training
and endurance exercise.
And, indeed, that's
what I've found.
So I use it largely
for preparing
for podcasts or other
aspects of my scientific work
and sometimes prior to
workouts, especially
if I'm working out having
not consumed any food prior.
I find that I have
a lot more energy.
It also has the property
of suppressing hunger.
If you'd like to try Ketone-IQ,
you can go to HVMN.com/Huberman
to save 20%.
Again, that's HVMN.com/Huberman
to save 20% off your order
of Ketone-IQ.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by Thesis.
Thesis makes custom nootropics.
And as many of you have
probably heard me say before,
I am not a fan of
the word nootropics
because nootropics
means smart drugs.
And, frankly, the brain
doesn't work that way.
The brain has neural
circuits for focus.
It also has neural circuits
for creativity and neural
circuits for task switching and
for imagination and for memory.
There is no such thing as a
neural circuit for being smart.
And therefore, the
word nootropics
doesn't really apply to anything
specific neurobiologically
speaking.
Thesis understands
this and therefore has
designed custom
nootropics that are
tailored to your unique needs.
I've been using Thesis
for over a year now,
and their nootropic
formulas have
been a game changer
for me, in particular
in the realm of cognitive work.
My go-to formula
for when I'm doing
any kind of cognitive work
is their Clarity formula.
That's the one I've been
using most often lately.
If you'd like to try Thesis
customized nootropics,
you can go online to
TakeThesis.com/Huberman.
You'll take a brief
three-minute quiz.
And Thesis will send you
four different formulas
to try in your first month.
Again, that's
TakeThesis.com/Huberman and use
the code Huberman at checkout
for 10% off your first box.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by WHOOP.
WHOOP is a fitness
wearable device
that tracks your daily
activity and your sleep
but goes beyond that by
providing real-time feedback
on how to adjust your
training and sleep
schedule to perform better.
I've been working with WHOOP
on their scientific advisory
council to help WHOOP
evolve their mission
to improve the way that
people are sleeping
and thereby to improve
their levels of focus, mood,
and alertness and performance
in all endeavors during the day.
As a WHOOP user,
I've experienced
the health benefits, the focus
benefits, essentially all
of the major benefits
that come with getting
an excellent night's sleep
on a consistent basis.
I've also learned from
using my WHOOP how
certain daily activities,
like the timing of exercise,
caffeine, and a number
of other things,
impact the depth, quality,
and duration of my sleep.
WHOOP is one of those
tools that can really
help guide you and provide
you with personalized data,
recommendations, and
coaching around your body
and your overall health.
So it's not just
about tracking sleep.
It's about tracking all
aspects of your activity
and health and, of
course, including sleep.
If you're interested
in trying WHOOP,
you can go to
Join.WHOOP.com/Huberman today
and get your first month free.
Let's talk about breathing.
And, of course, we
breathe in order
to bring oxygen into the body.
But we also breathe to remove
certain things from our body,
in particular carbon dioxide.
So the main players
in today's discussion
are going to be oxygen
and carbon dioxide.
Now, a common misconception
is that oxygen is good
and carbon dioxide is bad.
That's simply not the case.
Let's just take a step
back from that statement,
and let's think about this.
When we breathe
in, we are largely
breathing in air in order to
bring oxygen into our body.
And we can just stop
right there and say,
why do we breathe at all?
Why can't we just get oxygen
from the world around us?
Well, it's because oxygen
can't diffuse through our skin
into the deeper
cells of our body.
Other single cell and
very simple organisms
can actually bring
oxygen into their system
without the need to breathe.
But we have to breathe
in order to bring oxygen
to the cells that
reside deep in our body.
In particular, our
brain cells, which
are the most metabolically
active cells in our body,
require a lot of oxygen.
And those brain cells
are sitting, of course,
in the brain, which
is encased in the
cranial vault, the skull.
And so oxygen can't simply
pass to those cells.
So we need to have a system
that will deliver oxygen
to those cells.
We also need a system,
which turns out
to be the breathing or
respiratory system, that
can offload or remove the
gas that we call carbon
dioxide, not because
carbon dioxide is bad
but because too much of it
in our system is not good.
In fact, much of
today's discussion
will also center around
the common misconception
that carbon dioxide is something
that we want to get rid of.
You don't want to get rid of
too much carbon dioxide or else
you can't actually get oxygen
to the cells and tissues
of your body in
an efficient way.
So you need oxygen and you need
carbon dioxide in your body.
You also need to be able
to offload or remove
carbon dioxide and bring in
oxygen in the correct ratios
so that you can perform the
kind of mental functions
and physical functions
that you want to.
So if we just dial
out even further,
we say, what are the key
components of breathing?
What are the elements
within the body that
allow us to bring oxygen
to the tissues and cells
as is required and remove
carbon dioxide from the body
as is required and yet keep
enough carbon dioxide around
in order to allow
oxygen to do its thing?
Well, that breathing or
respiratory apparatus
has two major
components, and I'm
going to just briefly
describe those.
And as I do this, I really
want to highlight the fact
that any time you're thinking
about biology and physiology
in particular, whether or
not it's about the brain
or the liver or
the gut microbiome,
it's useful to categorize things
either as mechanical mechanisms
or chemical mechanisms.
What do I mean by that?
Well, let's just take
the analogy of hunger.
There are mechanical
mechanisms that
tell us when we should eat.
For instance, you have neurons,
nerve cells in your gut
that signal how
stretched or nonstretched
the walls of your
stomach are, how full
or how empty your gut is,
and send that information
to the brain to make you feel
to some extent hungry or not
hungry.
In general, when our
stomach is very full
and especially if it's very
distended, even with liquid,
it suppresses our hunger.
Whereas when our stomach is
devoid of that mechanical
pressure, especially
for a number of hours,
it tends to trigger
hunger by signaling
via neurons to the brain.
In addition, there are chemical
signals that go from the gut
to the brain.
For instance, we have
neurons in our gut
that can detect the
presence of amino acids
from proteins that we eat,
fatty acids from the foods
that we eat, the lipids,
and sugars, different forms
of carbohydrate.
The neurons in our gut
are paying attention to
or respond to how much
amino acid, fatty acid,
and carbohydrate is in
our gut and sends signals
to the brain to either
stimulate or suppress hunger.
So those are
chemical signals that
are being passed
from gut to brain,
and they work in parallel
with the mechanical signals.
And this idea of
"in parallel with,"
again, is a very common
theme in biology,
especially neuroscience.
The term parallel pathways
refers to the fact
that any time there's a
critical bodily function,
it's very unlikely that just
one type of information,
like just mechanical
information,
is going to be used.
/ Almost always,
it's going to be mechanical
and chemical information.
I could pick a number
of other examples.
For instance, if
you want to avoid
damaging your skin or other
tissues of your body, which
is essential to life, well, then
you have mechanical information
about, for instance,
whether or not something
is pinching or ready
to pierce your skin.
That's mechanical information.
It's sent via specific
neurons up to the brain
to signal a retraction
reflex if you
move your limb away from
wherever that intense pressure
is coming.
You also have chemical
sensing in your skin,
the presence of things
that elicit a burn
or that elicit itch or
that elicit extreme cold.
All of that chemical
information is
being signaled up to the
brain as well in parallel.
So parallel pathways
is a common theme.
So when we're thinking about
the respiration, a.k.a.
the breathing,
system, we also need
to look at the
mechanical system.
What are the
different components
of the nose, the mouth,
the lungs, et cetera, that
allow oxygen to be
brought in and carbon
dioxide to be removed from the
body but not too much carbon
dioxide removed
to allow breathing
to work as efficiently and
as optimally as possible?
And then we also need to
look at the chemical systems
of the lungs, the bloodstream,
and how different cells use
oxygen and carbon
dioxide in order
to understand that as well.
If you can understand the
mechanical and chemical aspects
of breathing, even
just at a top contour,
well, then the
various tools that I
discuss during today's
episode, such as the ability
to calm yourself down most
quickly by doing what's
called a physiological sigh--
I'll go into this in more
detail in a little bit,
but this is two very deep
inhales through the nose.
So the first one is a long
inhale [INHALES DEEPLY],,
and then the second one after
that is [INHALES SHARPLY]
a quick, sharp inhale to
maximally inflate your lungs,
followed by a full exhale
through the mouth to lungs
completely empty.
So it's big inhale
through the nose,
then short inhale
through the nose
immediately after that in order
to maximally inflate the lungs,
and then a long exhale
through the mouth
until your lungs are empty.
You will understand why that
particular pattern of breathing
and not simply one
inhale or not simply
an inhale through the nose
and an exhale through the nose
as well is optimal for
reducing your stress quickly.
That double inhale through the
nose followed by a long exhale
through the mouth works to
reduce your levels of stress
and lower your levels of
so-called autonomic arousal
very fast in real time.
And it works better than
any other known approach.
It's not a hack.
This is actually something
that your body has
specific neural circuits
to do, and it actually
performs during sleep on
a regular basis and even
throughout the day, and that
you can perform voluntarily.
And it works so well
to reduce stress
very quickly not
because it brings
in the maximum amount
of oxygen and removes
the maximum amount of
carbon dioxide but,
rather, because it optimally
balances oxygen and carbon
dioxide.
If you understand the
mechanical and chemical aspects
of breathing, then you
will understand exactly why
that particular
pattern of breathing,
the so-called
physiological sigh,
is the most efficient
way to rapidly reduce
stress in real time.
If you can understand the
mechanical and chemical aspects
of breathing, you will
also understand why
most people are overbreathing.
That is, they're breathing
too often, even if they're
breathing in a shallow manner.
They're breathing too often.
And they are blowing off
or removing too much carbon
dioxide.
And if you understand
that carbon dioxide is
critical for the way
that oxygen is delivered
from the bloodstream to
the tissues of the body,
including the
brain, well, then it
will make very good
sense as to why
people who are
breathing too much
don't actually experience all
the effects of elevated oxygen,
but, rather, they're putting
their body into what's
called a hypoxic state.
They're not getting
enough oxygen
to the tissues of their body,
in particular their brain.
And this is true not just
for people who are obese
or who suffer from sleep apnea,
although that's certainly
the case, but for people
that have, believe it or not,
certain personality types.
We'll talk about breathing
and personality type
and actually how
breathing has been
shown to alter personality.
That's right.
Breathing can alter personality
in positive ways that
allow anyone to show up to the
various social and nonsocial
endeavors of their life
with more calm, more focus,
alertness, and improve
their overall health.
OK, so let's talk about
the mechanical components
of breathing.
It's really quite simple.
You've got your nose, obviously,
and you've got your mouth.
And a little bit
later, we'll talk
about the incredible advantages
of being a nasal breather
most of the time but also
the incredible advantages
of using your mouth to breathe
both for inhales and exhales
during particular
types of endeavors.
And we'll get back to
that a little later.
But for the meantime,
the only two ways
to bring air into your
system are through your nose
and through your mouth.
We also have the larynx, which
is a rigid tissue or pipe that
brings the air from the nose
and mouth down to the lungs.
Now, that word rigid is
really important here
because what we will soon learn
is that your lungs basically
act like a pump.
You sort of know this already.
But these are two
big bags basically
that can fill with air or
that can squeeze air out.
Now, what most
people don't realize
is that the lungs are not
just too big bags of air.
Your lungs are actually too big
bags of air that inside of them
have hundreds of
millions of little sacs
that are called the
alveoli of the lungs.
And by having those hundreds
of millions of little sacs,
you increase the surface
area of the lungs.
And by increasing
the surface area,
you allow more oxygen to pass
from the air in your lungs
into the bloodstream than if
you didn't have those sacs.
And you allow more
carbon dioxide
to move from the bloodstream
into those sacs of the lungs,
and then when you exhale, the
carbon dioxide can be removed.
So those little sacs we
call alveoli of the lungs
are an important part
of the mechanical aspect
of breathing we'll get
to a little bit later.
So at a first pass, the
mechanical aspects of breathing
are really straightforward.
You can breathe
through your nose.
You can through your mouth.
It goes down through the larynx.
I told you the larynx
is a rigid pipe.
The lungs are not rigid.
They can expand and
they can contract
like a pump to bring
in air or to expel air.
Keep in mind that
the lungs do not
have any muscles themselves.
So we need muscles that can
either squeeze the lungs
or that will allow
the lungs to expand.
And there are two general
groups of muscles that do that,
and they are the diaphragm
and the so-called intercostal
muscles.
The diaphragm is a thin muscle
that sits below the lungs
and above the liver.
And when we inhale,
provided that we
are using what's called
diaphragmatic breathing, that
diaphragm contracts.
And when it contracts,
it moves down,
which allows more space for
the lungs to inflate with air.
Now, the intercostal muscles are
the muscles between our ribs.
A number of people probably
don't realize this.
But your ribs, of
course, are bone,
but in between those
bones, you have muscles.
And the intercostal
muscles, when you inhale,
contract, and that allows
your rib cage to move up
and to expand a bit.
And I think, again,
people probably
don't realize that your
ribs are not fixed in place.
They can actually get
further and closer apart
from one another.
So when you inhale, your
rib cage actually moves up.
Sometimes the shoulders
will move up as well.
And that's because those
intercostal muscles
are contracting.
Now, muscles can't
move on their own.
They are controlled by nerves.
So we've got the nose,
the mouth, the larynx,
and the lungs.
The lungs have all those
little alveoli in them.
And as I told you,
we've got the diaphragm
as a muscle to move
the lungs, and we
have the intercostal muscles
to move the ribs, which
can allow the lungs to expand.
Again, we're just on the
mechanical components
of breathing.
But because muscles
can't move themselves,
you should be asking,
what moves the muscles?
And it's really nerves
that control muscles.
So whether or not you're
contracting your biceps
or you're walking and you're
contracting your quadriceps
and your hamstrings
and your calf muscles,
it's neurons, nerve
cells that control that.
There's a specialized nerve
called the phrenic nerve,
P-H-R-E-N-I-C, phrenic nerve,
that comes out of the neck.
And when I say it comes out
of the neck, what I mean
is that there are little neurons
that reside in the brainstem,
in the back of your brain,
and they send little wires
that we call axons down
and out of the neck.
They go close to the heart
and a little bit behind it.
And they go down, and
they form synapses.
That is, they form connections
with the diaphragm.
And when those neurons release
neurotransmitters, which
are little chemicals,
the diaphragm contracts,
and it moves down.
So we say that the phrenic
nerve is a motor nerve.
It's designed to move muscle.
However, the phrenic nerve, like
a few other nerves in the body,
is interesting in that it has
not just motor nerves in there,
neurons that control the
contraction of muscles.
It also can sense things,
has sensory neurons.
So it also sends connections
down to the diaphragm
and actually down deep
into the diaphragm
and close to the liver.
And note that I said
liver twice now already,
and we're going to
get back to this later
when we talk about
physical movement
and cramps of the body.
Those sensory neurons dive
deep into the diaphragm.
And then they go
back up to the brain,
and they allow you to sense
where the diaphragm is.
So they're giving
information about where
the diaphragm is in your body.
Now, most of the time, you're
not paying attention to this.
But right now, you
can actually try this.
And I would encourage
you to do this.
Diaphragmatic breathing
is, in many ways,
the ideal way to breathe and
that it's the most efficient
way to breathe.
We'll talk about what
we mean exactly when we
say breathing efficiency later.
But the diaphragm
is designed to allow
the lungs to expand or
to contract the lungs,
to bring air into
the body or to remove
carbon dioxide from the body.
And if you want to
know whether or not
you're using diaphragmatic
breathing, it's very simple.
If you inhale-- probably best
to do this through the nose,
but you could do it
through the mouth.
If you inhale and your belly
moves outward on the inhale,
well, then that phrenic nerve
is controlling your diaphragm
properly.
And then when you
exhale, your belly
should go in just a little bit.
That's diaphragmatic breathing.
Now, diaphragmatic
breathing is talked
about in the context of yoga.
It's often talked about as a
way to calm down and so on.
But diaphragmatic
breathing is just one mode
by which your brain
and the phrenic nerve
can control muscle,
the diaphragm,
to control the mechanical
aspects of the lungs
to bring in air and expel air.
As I mentioned
before, you also have
these muscles between your ribs
or the intercostal muscles.
And there's a
separate set of nerves
that allow those muscles to
contract and for your rib cage
to expand in order to create
more room for your lungs
to get larger and fill with
air or for your rib cage
to contract a bit when
those muscles relax in order
to expel air.
I'd like to go on
record by saying
that there is no rule that
diaphragmatic breathing is
better than breathing
where your rib cage moves.
This is a common misconception.
People say, oh, if your
shoulders are going up and down
and your rib cage is moving
while you're breathing,
well, then you're
not breathing right.
And if your belly goes out
and the rest of your body
is still while you
breathe, well, then you're
breathing correctly.
I know of zero--
in fact, zero minus one data
to support that statement.
You have multiple
parallel mechanisms
to control the mechanics of
your lungs and for breathing.
And when you're exerting
yourself very hard,
you tend to use both
the intercostal muscles
and your rib cage moving as
well as your diaphragm in order
to bring in a lot of
oxygen and to offload
a lot of carbon dioxide.
And when you're
calmer, frankly, you
could use
diaphragmatic breathing
or you could use rib cage
type breathing in order
to bring enough oxygen
into your system.
There's no real data showing
that diaphragmatic breathing is
somehow better or worse.
However, being able to
mechanically control those
independently or to combine
them and use them together
is of tremendous power
toward regulating
your mental and physical states.
And we'll talk about how to
do that a little bit later.
For right now, please
understand that you
have these different
mechanical components that
allow you to bring oxygen into
your system and to expel air
and to thereby offload carbon
dioxide from your system.
Again, we haven't talked about
the gas exchange of carbon
dioxide and oxygen
and how that's
happening in the bloodstream.
We'll talk about that next.
But the basic mechanical
components are pretty simple.
Once again, just to review,
it's nose, mouth, larynx, lungs,
alveoli within the lungs,
and then those two muscles,
the diaphragm and the
intercostal muscles
of the ribs.
And one thing I
failed to mention
is why it's so important that
that larynx be rigid, that it's
a tube that is very rigid.
And the reason for that is
that unlike the lungs, which
you want to act as
sort of a bellow pump
where you can deflate it and
inflate it in order to move air
in and out, the larynx
needs to be rigid
so that it doesn't collapse
while you're bringing air
in and out.
You can imagine that if it was
a very flimsy tube or the walls
of the larynx were
very flimsy and thin,
well, then you can imagine
breathing in very vigorously,
and it would shut
like a tube that
suddenly flattens on itself,
which would not be good.
So the fact that
the larynx is rigid
is actually a very crucial
part of this whole system.
The other important
aspect of this system
as it relates to the
mechanics of breathing
is the fact that your
nose and your mouth
have different
resistances to air.
You can probably
notice this right now
if you were to, for
instance, breathe
in through your mouth
[INHALES] and only
through your mouth
versus breathing
through your nose [SNIFFS].
Some of you perhaps have
a harder time breathing in
through your nose.
By the way, it's
perfectly normal
that one or the
other nostril would
be harder to breathe through
or easier to breathe through
and that switches
across the day.
It has to do with the flow
of mucus and cerebrospinal
fluid and intracranial pressure.
Totally normal.
Many people out
there think they have
a deviated septum
who don't actually
have a deviated septum.
A little bit later,
we'll talk about how
to repair a deviated septum
without surgery because that
actually is possible
in many, not all, cases
and is immensely
beneficial to do.
But what we know is that
breathing in through the nose
is a little bit harder,
and it's supposed
to be a little bit harder.
However, because it's a little
bit harder because there's
more resistance, as we
say, you are actually
able to draw more force into
these mechanical aspects
of the breathing
apparatus and actually
bring more air into your lungs.
You can try this right now.
Try breathing in through your
mouth to maximally inflate
your lungs and try and do it
through mostly diaphragmatic
breathing, just for
sake of example.
In other words, try and
breathe in through your mouth.
And as you do that, have your
belly expand and maximally
inflate your lungs.
I'll do it right now with you
so that we can do it together
and I can prove to
everyone that I'm just as
deficient in this as you are.
[INHALES]
OK, so I can inflate
my stomach doing that.
But now try doing
it with your nose,
and please do exhale before you
try doing it with your nose.
With your nose, you're going
to feel more resistance,
but you'll notice that you can
inflate it quite a bit further.
[SNIFFS] And you'll feel your
entire cavity, your belly
and maybe even in your lower
back, fill with some pressure.
So the increased
resistance actually
allows you to draw more
air into the system.
This turns out to
be very important.
And it also wipes away
a common misconception,
which is if you're somebody
who has challenges breathing in
through your nose, that somehow
you should avoid breathing in
through your nose, actually,
quite the opposite is true.
And we can go a
step further and say
that if you have challenges
breathing in through your nose,
chances are that's
because the increased
resistance of breathing
in through your nose,
provided it's not
completely occluded,
is going to allow you to bring
more oxygen into your system.
This will turn out to
be useful later when
we explore different
techniques, for instance,
not just to calm down
quickly but to elevate
your energy quickly, to remove
a cramp during exercise,
and a number of other
things that breathing
can be used for that
can be immensely
useful for mental and
physical challenges.
I'd like to take a quick
break and acknowledge
one of our sponsors,
Athletic Greens.
Athletic Greens, now called AG1,
is a vitamin mineral probiotic
drink that covers all of your
foundational nutritional needs.
I've been taking Athletic
Green since 2012.
So I'm delighted that they're
sponsoring the podcast.
The reason I started taking
Athletic Greens and the reason
I still take Athletic Greens
once or usually twice a day
is that it gets
me the probiotics
that I need for gut health.
Our gut is very important.
It's populated by
gut microbiota that
communicate with the brain, the
immune system, and basically
all the biological
systems of our body
to strongly impact our
immediate and long-term health.
And those probiotics
in the Athletic Greens
are optimal and vital
for microbiota health.
In addition, Athletic
Greens contains a number
of adaptogens,
vitamins, and minerals
that make sure that all of my
foundational nutritional needs
are met.
And it tastes great.
If you'd like to
try Athletic Greens,
you can go to
AthleticGreens.com/Huberman,
and they'll give you five
free travel packs that make it
really easy to mix up
Athletic Greens while
you're on the road, in the
car, on the plane, et cetera.
And they'll give you a year
supply of vitamin D3/K2.
Again, that's
AthleticGreens.com/Huberman
to get the five free travel
packs and the year's supply
of vitamin D3/K2.
So now let's talk about the
chemical aspects of breathing.
And the two major players
in this discussion
are oxygen, which all the cells
and tissues of your body need,
and carbon dioxide,
which all the cells
and tissues of your body need.
In fact, carbon dioxide
plays critical roles
in delivering oxygen
to your cells.
And without carbon
dioxide, you're
not going to get enough
oxygen to the cells
and tissues of your body.
That said, if carbon
dioxide levels are too high,
that is very problematic.
In fact, one of the ways that
one can reliably induce panic
in anybody is to
have them breathe
air that contains too
much carbon dioxide,
so much so that for
people that lack
a so-called
amygdala-- many of you
have probably heard
of the amygdala.
This is a brain area that's
associated with fear and threat
detection.
Even in people who
completely lack amygdalas
on both sides of the brain
because they were removed
because they had
epileptic seizures there
and, therefore, those people are
completely unafraid of things
that they ought to be
afraid of like heights,
poisonous snakes, any
number of different things
dangerous to humans,
well, if those people
breathe an excess amount
of carbon dioxide,
they immediately
have a panic attack.
What that tells us
is that, again, there
are parallel mechanisms,
there's redundancy in the system
to protect ourselves from
having too much carbon
dioxide in our system.
So we need enough carbon dioxide
and enough oxygen in our system
but not too much.
The way that's accomplished is,
of course, we breathe in air.
Our lungs inflate.
And if you recall those
little alveoli of the lungs,
those little sacs, oxygen can
actually move from the air
into those little sacs and
then from those little sacs
into the vasculature--
the vasculature are
the capillaries, the veins,
and the arteries of the body--
because the walls of
those little alveoli
are exceedingly thin, and they
have tons of little capillaries
that go into them and
are all around them.
So this is amazing, right?
There's oxygen literally
passing from inside
of these little
sacs in our lungs
because we inhaled the
oxygen from the air
into the bloodstream,
and then that oxygen
gets bound up by
proteins in the blood,
in particular hemoglobin.
And hemoglobin then
delivers oxygen
to the various cells
and tissues of the body.
However, oxygen can't just
hop on hemoglobin and cruise
along with hemoglobin until
it gets to, say, your brain
and then hop off.
It doesn't work that way.
You require carbon
dioxide in order
to liberate oxygen
from hemoglobin.
Carbon dioxide has this
incredible property
of actually being able to
change the shape of hemoglobin.
Hemoglobin is shaped as a
sort of a cage around oxygen
molecules.
And when it's in
that cage shape,
the oxygen can't be liberated.
So you've got oxygen and
hemoglobin bound to one another
moving through your bloodstream.
But if a tissue
needs oxygen, there
needs to be carbon dioxide
present to open up that cage.
And that's what
carbon dioxide does.
It allows that cage
to change shape,
and then the oxygen
can be liberated
and then can be
delivered to the tissues,
whether or not that's brain
tissue or muscle tissue,
so on and so forth.
And so those are the
major chemical components
of breathing.
There are a few
other aspects related
to the chemical
components of breathing,
such as the fact that carbon
dioxide is strongly related
to how acidic or how basic
your body is in general.
So for instance, if carbon
dioxide levels go way down,
your blood pH goes way up.
That is, you become
more alkaline.
Now, for many people, the word
pH and the whole concept of pH
immediately starts to evoke
anxiety in and of itself.
pH is actually very simple.
You want the body basically
to be at a pH of about 7.4.
There are some
regions of your body,
in particular along the gut,
for which that number is
importantly different in order
for digestion to work properly.
You've all heard of the gut
microbiome, the little microbes
that, provided you
have enough of them
and they're diverse enough,
allow your brain and body
to function optimally at the
level of immune system, hormone
system, brain, et cetera.
Well, in the gut, you
want the pH sometimes
be slightly more acidic.
Because when it's more
acidic, the little microbiota
flourish far more than
if it were more basic.
But basically, you want
the rest of the body
to be at about pH 7.4.
If carbon dioxide levels go to
low, the pH increases in a way
that you might say,
oh, well, that's bad,
but that actually
allows more oxygen
to be available to the
tissues of your body, at least
temporarily.
We'll talk about this
a bit more later.
If I'm losing any of
you, just hang in there
because we're almost done
with this whole business
of the mechanics and the
chemistry of breathing,
and then we can get into the
tools and revisit some of this
later to clean up any
misunderstandings that
may have arisen.
But as we're talking about
carbon dioxide over and over
again and how key it is to have
carbon dioxide and the problems
with it going too
high to low, you
should probably be asking
yourself, what actually makes
carbon dioxide go too low?
We know that we
breathe in oxygen,
and then it can pass from
the lungs and the alveoli
into the bloodstream and that we
need carbon dioxide to liberate
oxygen from the
hemoglobin into the cells
and tissues of the body.
And we know that
when we exhale--
well, actually, I haven't
told you this yet.
But you should know
that when you exhale,
carbon dioxide is actually
taken from the bloodstream
back into the
alveoli of the lungs.
And then when you exhale, it's
expelled through your mouth
or through your nose
out into the world.
So the way I just described all
that-- inhale, bring in oxygen,
exhale, expel carbon dioxide--
pretty straightforward, right?
Indeed, it is.
And it also tells
you that were you
to exhale a lot more or
a lot more vigorously,
you would expel
more carbon dioxide.
And in fact, that's
exactly the way it works.
When you hyperventilate,
of course, you
are inhaling more than
usual, but you are also
exhaling more than usual.
So you're, of course, bringing
in more air and oxygen
to your body.
But you're also removing more
carbon dioxide from your body
than normal.
Carbon dioxide, because of the
ways that it regulates brain
state-- in fact, the way
in which it regulates
the excitability, literally
the ability of your neurons
to engage electrically or not--
it can create states of
panic and anxiety, which
is why when you
hyperventilate, you
feel an increase
in anxiety, or when
you feel an increase in
anxiety, you hyperventilate.
It's a reciprocal relationship.
In fact, I don't want
anyone who has anxiety
or who has panic
attacks to try this now.
But for most people,
it's probably safe
as long as you're not driving
or doing something mechanical
or operating machinery, that is.
Probably safe to do 25 or
30 deep inhales and exhales.
And you'll notice that
by about breath 10,
you'll start to feel
tingly, and you'll probably
feel a little bit more alert.
And, again, if you have anxiety
or panic attack tendencies,
please don't do this.
But you will feel an increase
in so-called autonomic arousal,
an increase in the activity
of your overall sympathetic
nervous system, which has
nothing to do with sympathy,
has everything to
do with alertness.
You'll actually deploy
adrenaline from your adrenals.
So I'll just do this now.
You can try this now, again,
provided you're in a safe place
and you don't have anxiety
or panic attack tendencies.
You would just breathe
in through your nose
and out through your mouth.
Remember, we're breathing
in more and more vigorously,
and we're exhaling more and
more vigorously than we normally
would.
It goes something like this.
[INHALING, EXHALING]
Now, by breath 8
or 9 or 10, you'll
notice that your body
starts to heat up.
That's due to a
couple of things,
mainly the release of
adrenaline from your adrenals.
I'm already feeling a
little bit lightheaded.
The lightheadedness is actually
because your vasculature,
the capillaries and veins
and, to some extent,
even the arteries of your body
and particularly in your brain,
are actually starting
to constrict.
So you're cutting off
blood flow to the brain.
Why?
Well, because carbon dioxide
actually is a vasodilator.
Normally, it exists in your
body to keep capillaries, veins,
and arteries dilated to allow
blood to pass through them.
When you hyperventilate,
sure, you're
bringing in a lot
of oxygen, which
you think would make you more
alert, and, indeed, it does.
But you are also expelling
a lot more carbon dioxide
than you normally would.
And that's causing
some vasoconstriction,
and you're going
to start feeling
tingly in the periphery,
in your fingers and toes
perhaps or your legs.
You will also notice that you're
feeling more alert in the brain
but that you might start
to feel a bit of anxiety.
So hyperventilation, yes,
brings in more oxygen,
also removes more
carbon dioxide.
The removal of
excess carbon dioxide
puts you into a state that's
called hypocapnic, hypoxia.
Hypoxia is reduced levels of
oxygen relative to normal.
Hypocapnia is reduced
levels of carbon dioxide
relative to normal.
And it is those reduced
levels of carbon dioxide
that are largely responsible
for that elevation
in energy and at the same time
a feeling of a bit of anxiety,
the construction of
the microvasculature
in the brain and
body, and therefore
the feelings of
being kind of tingly
and having kind of
an urgency to move.
OK, so by now, it
should be clear
that we need both oxygen
and carbon dioxide.
And across the course
of this episode,
I will explain how to adjust
those ratios of oxygen
to carbon dioxide depending on
what your immediate needs are
and what you plan to
do next, whether or not
that's sleep or exercise
or mental work, et cetera.
Before going any
further, however, there
is something I want to touch on.
Because even though not
everyone will experience this,
I think enough
people experience it
that it is of
interest, and now's
the right time to touch into
what happens when you go up
to a very high altitude, meaning
why it's hard to breathe when
you get up to high altitudes.
So if you're close
to sea level, you
are getting out of the
optimal balance of oxygen
in the air you breathe.
As you ascend in
altitude-- so let's
say you go to 6,000
feet or 10,000
or maybe even 11,000
feet above sea level.
Or maybe you're one of
those rare individuals that
climbs Denali, or you
climb Mount Everest,
and you get up there, and you
notice that most people are
going to wear an oxygen mask.
Why is it that you need an
oxygen mask at those very high
altitudes or when people
do these very high altitude
skydives that they need
oxygen way up high?
Well, a lot of people will say,
oh, there's not much oxygen
up there.
The air is thinner.
OK, well, perhaps a better
way to think about it
is that, remember
when we were talking
about the mechanical aspects
of breathing and the fact
that the lungs don't
really move themselves,
that they have the
muscles, the diaphragm
and the intercostal
muscles to move them?
Well, a lot of the reason why
your lungs can fill so readily
with air is that when you don't
have much air in your lungs,
there's very low air pressure in
your lungs relative to outside
you.
So what we mean
then is if you were
to open up your mouth
[INHALES] or your nose
and breathe in, that is,
breathe in through your nose
or mouth, what's
going to happen is
air is going to move from
high pressure to low pressure.
So it's very easy
to fill your lungs.
Even though you
need those muscles
to move the various
things around that
allow your lungs
to fill, the air
is going to go from high
pressure to low pressure.
So [INHALES] for those
of you listening,
I just took a big
inhale through my nose.
And then when you exhale, you're
basically taking the lungs
from a state in
which the pressure is
really high in the
lungs, high pressure,
like a balloon that's full--
and the pressure in your
lungs when your lungs are full
is higher than the air outside.
So it's pretty easy
[EXHALES] to expel that air
through the nose or mouth.
When you're at high altitudes,
the air pressure is lower.
And so what happens is when
the air pressure is lower
outside your body and your
lungs are not full of air,
you don't have that
really steep gradient
of high pressure
outside the body
to low pressure
inside your lungs.
And so you actually have
to put a lot more effort
into breathing air
into your lungs.
You have to really
exert a lot of force.
You have to get the diaphragm,
those intercostal muscles
working really hard.
You might even find that
your shoulders are lifting
with each breath [INHALES]
because you really
have to generate a lot of
force to get enough air
and oxygen into your lungs.
Now, an important
principle to understand
is that in humans, and
in some other species,
but really what we're
talking about now
is humans, when you inhale,
that's an active process.
You really need to
use those muscles
of the intercostals
and the diaphragm
in order to inflate the lungs.
But the whole process
is made easier
when air pressure
outside your body
is higher than it
is in your lungs
because then they're going
to fill up really readily.
Exhaling, at least for
humans, is a passive thing.
You just have to
relax the diaphragm
and relax the intercostals and
let the rib cage kind of fall
back to its original position.
So inhaling is active,
and exhaling is passive.
And so what happens is if
you're at a high altitude
and the air pressure
is very low,
then you have to
put a lot of energy
into breathing air
into your lungs
to get an equivalent amount
of oxygen into your lungs
and then into the bloodstream.
So that's why when you arrive
at a high altitude location,
for the first few days, you're
going to feel lightheaded
maybe a headache.
You're also going to have
more buildup of carbon
dioxide in your system.
And so the whole balance of
oxygen and carbon dioxide
is going to be disrupted.
I mention all that
because, yes, indeed, there
are some changes in
the atmospheric gases
at high altitudes,
and that can impact
how much oxygen you can
bring into your system,
into your tissues.
But I've heard many explanations
of why it's hard to breathe
or why you feel
lousy at altitude.
Well, you just
discovered one reason,
which is that you don't have
that steep high pressure
to low pressure gradient
from the outside of the body
into the inside of the body.
The converse is also true.
If you've been at
altitude for a few days
and you've had the opportunity
to adjust-- a lot of athletes,
for instance, will
go train at altitude.
It's hard for them in
the first days or weeks,
and then they get really
good at training at altitude.
There are a number of
different adaptations
that occur in terms of
the amount of oxygen
that can be carried in
the blood by hemoglobin
and the interactions between
carbon dioxide and hemoglobin
and oxygen that
allow more oxygen
to be delivered to the tissues,
such that, at altitude,
you can function just normally.
But if you then move very
quickly from altitude-- say,
you've been training at
8,000 feet or 10,000 feet.
You've been hiking up at that
high level, and you've adapted,
and you come down to sea level.
Well, for about
two to five days,
you're going to feel
like an absolute beast.
You're going to be able
to essentially deliver
far more oxygen to your
muscles per breath.
In part, that is
because of the way
that the hemoglobin and the
oxygen that it's carrying
has been altered when you
were at high altitude.
But it's also because when you
were at that high altitude,
those intercostal muscles
and those diaphragms
got trained up quite a bit and
allowed you to generate more
air volume for every breath.
In other words, those
muscles got stronger,
and you got more efficient
at driving the phrenic nerve
consciously to [INHALES] really
breathe in a lot of oxygen
so you don't feel lightheaded,
headache, et cetera.
OK, so that's a little
bit of an aside.
But it's an important aside,
I believe, because, A,
it answers a question
a lot of people ask
and they a lot of people
wonder about and, B,
because it incorporates both the
mechanical aspects of breathing
and the chemical
aspects of breathing.
I realize it's a little bit
of a unusual circumstance.
But now if anyone
asks you why it's
hard to breathe at
altitude, you know
it has to do with this
lack of a high pressure
to low pressure
gradient across the body
and with the
atmosphere outside you.
It's also an opportunity
for me to say
that if you do find
yourself at altitude
and you have a headache or
you're feeling like you just
can't catch your breath,
spending some time really
consciously trying to draw
in larger breaths of air,
as much as that
might seem fatiguing
and you'll be short of
breath, it will allow
you to adapt more quickly.
And a little bit
later in the episode,
we'll touch on a few
methods, including
deliberate hyperventilation
combined with some breath
holds, that can allow
you to deliver more
oxygen to the cells
immediately upon arriving
at altitude so you
don't get quite
as much headache,
disorientation, and so on.
So leaving breathing
at altitude aside let's
all come back down to the
same conceptual level.
We can ask ourselves,
for instance,
what is healthy breathing, and
what is unhealthy breathing?
And the first place
we want to tackle this
is within the context of sleep.
So when we go to sleep at
night, we continue to breathe.
That's no surprise.
If we didn't, we would
die during sleep.
However, there is
a large fraction
of the population that
underbreathes during sleep.
They're not taking deep enough
or frequent enough breaths.
And therefore, they
are experiencing
what's called sleep apnea.
They are becoming
hypoxic, hypo-oxic.
There's less oxygen being
brought into their system
than is necessary.
People that are
carrying excess weight,
either fat weight or
muscle weight or both,
are more prone to
nighttime sleep apnea.
However, there are
a lot of people
who are not overweight who
also experience sleep apnea.
How do you know if you're
experiencing sleep apnea?
Well, first of all,
excessive daytime sleepiness
and excessive daytime
anxiety combined
with daytime
sleepiness is one sign
that you might be
suffering from sleep apnea.
The other thing is if
you happen to snore,
it's very likely that you
are experiencing sleep apnea.
And I should mention that sleep
apnea is a very serious health
concern.
It greatly increases
the probability
of a cardiovascular event,
heart attack, stroke.
It is a precursor or
sometimes the direct cause
of sexual dysfunction
in males and females.
Cognitive dysfunction
during the daytime.
It can exacerbate the
effects of dementia,
whether or not it's age-related
dementia of the normal sort
or Alzheimer's type
dementia, which
is an acceleration of
age-related cognitive decline.
If you're somebody who
has had a traumatic brain
injury, if you're
experiencing a lot of stress,
sleep apnea is going
to greatly disrupt
the amount of oxygen brought
in to your brain and body
during sleep and
is going to lead
to a number of nighttime
and daytime issues.
So it's something that
really needs to be addressed.
And we'll get into
this a bit more later.
But since I raised
it as a problem,
I do want to raise the solution.
One of the major
treatments for sleep apnea
is that people will get
a CPAP device, which
is this face mask and a machine
that they'll sleep with.
And while those can
be very effective,
not everyone needs a CPAP.
One of the more common
methods nowadays
that's being used to
treat sleep apnea,
which is purely behavioral,
an intervention,
and is essentially zero
cost, is that people
are starting to
shift deliberately
to nasal breathing
during sleep because
of the additional resistance
of nasal breathing
and because of the
fact that there's
far less tendency if
any, excuse me, to snore
when nasal breathing.
Taping the mouth shut using
medical tape prior to sleep--
excuse me.
Putting medical tape on the
mouth prior to going to sleep
and then sleeping all night
with medical tape on the mouth
is one way that people can learn
to nasal breathe during sleep
and can greatly offset a
lot of sleep apnea, snoring,
and sleep-related issues.
A number of people
don't want to or don't
feel safe putting medical tape
on their mouth prior to sleep.
For some reason, they think
they're going to suffocate.
But, of course,
you would wake up
if you start to run out
of air at any moment.
So that's not so much a concern.
But what they'll do
is they will start
to use pure nasal breathing
during any type of exercise
or even just for some period
of time walking during the day
or while working.
And, again, later, we'll get
into the enormous benefits
of shifting to pure nasal
breathing when not exercising
hard, meaning at a rate
that you could normally
hold a conversation-- although
if you're pure nasal breathing,
you won't be holding
that conversation--
or when simply doing work
or any number of things
that are of low intensity.
You can train your system to
become a better nasal breather
during the daytime
through these deliberate
actions of taping the mouth
shut or just being conscious
of keeping your mouth shut.
And that, in addition to having
a number of positive health
and aesthetic effects
during the daytime,
is known to also transfer to
nighttime breathing patterns
and allow people to become
nasal breathers as opposed
to mouth breathers during
sleep and to snore less
and to have less sleep apnea.
Again, if you have
severe sleep apnea,
you probably do need
to check out a CPAP.
You should talk
to your physician.
But for people who have
minor sleep apnea or sleep
apnea that's starting
to take hold,
these other methods of shifting
to becoming a nasal breather
are going to be far more
beneficial and far more cost
effective than going all the way
to the CPAP, which, by the way,
doesn't really teach you
how to breathe properly
as much as it does adjust the
airflow going into your system.
That's an important point,
that when you shift from mouth
to nasal breathing
during sleep, you're
actually learning and
training your system
to breathe properly.
And when I say
learning and training
your system to breathe
properly, what do I mean?
Let's put some scientific
and mechanistic meat on that.
We already talked about the
phrenic nerve, this nerve
that innervates the diaphragm
and that allows for the lungs
to fill up because of the
movement of the diaphragm.
What we didn't talk
about, however,
were the brain
centers that actually
control the phrenic nerve
and control breathing.
Knowing about these two
brain areas and what they do
is extremely important, not just
for understanding the content
of this episode but for
understanding all of the tools
that we'll discuss and, indeed,
your general health as it
relates to respiration.
So there are basically
two areas of the brain
that control breathing.
The first is called the
pre-Botzinger complex.
You don't have to worry
about the name so much.
Just know that it was named
after a bottle of wine
and that it was discovered by
the great Jack Feldman, who's
a professor of neuroscience at
the University of California,
Los Angeles.
This is one of the most
fundamental discoveries
in all of neuroscience
in the last hundred years
or more because this brain area
that Jack and his colleagues
discovered controls all aspects
of breathing that are rhythmic,
that is, when inhales
follow exhales
follow inhales follow exhales.
That's all controlled
by a small set
of neurons in this
brainstem area,
so around the
region of the neck,
called the
pre-Botzinger complex.
And we really owe
a debt of gratitude
to Jack and his colleagues
for discovering that area
because it's involved in
everything from breathing when
we're asleep to
breathing when we're not
thinking about our breathing.
It may have a role--
that is, when its
function is disrupted,
it may cause things like
sudden infant death syndrome.
Believe it or not,
it can explain
in large part many of the deaths
related to the opioid crisis
because exogenous opioids
like fentanyl and other sorts
of drugs, which are
opioids obviously,
bind to opioid receptors on
that structure and shut it down.
Now, keep in mind these
neurons are designed
to be incredibly robust and
are designed to fire inhale,
exhale, inhale, exhale no
matter if we're awake or aware,
unaware or asleep
to keep us alive.
Exogenous opioids like
fentanyl and drugs
that are similar to that
can shut down that structure
because it's rich with
these opioid receptors.
So it binds to that,
and it shuts off
the pre-Botzinger
complex, which is
the major cause
of death of people
who die from opioid overdoses.
I think a lot of people
don't realize that.
They think, oh, the opioids
must shut off the brain
or shut down the heart.
No, it shuts down breathing.
So Jack's discovery
no doubt will
lead to some important things
as it relates to addiction,
and hopefully I think we frankly
can expect that it's also
going to eventually lead to
ways to prevent death in people
using opioids or
other types of drugs,
maybe by blocking
opioid receptors
in pre-Botzinger
complex using things
like naltrexone, et cetera.
In any event,
pre-Botzinger complex
is controlling inhale, exhale,
inhale, exhale patterns
of breathing.
The other brain center
controlling breathing, again,
through the phrenic nerve--
it all converges and goes
out through the phrenic nerve
in these intercostal muscles--
is the so-called
parafacial nucleus.
And the parafacial nucleus
is involved in patterns
of breathing where there is not
an inhale followed by exhale,
inhale followed by exhale--
that is, it's not rhythmic,
one than the other--
but, rather, where there
is a doubling up of inhales
or a doubling up of exhales or
a deliberate pause in breathing,
so inhale, pause, exhale, pause,
inhale, pause, exhale, pause,
this sort of thing.
A little bit later, we'll
talk about a pattern
of breathing called
box breathing, which
has very specific and
useful applications,
in particular for
adjusting anxiety.
And in that case, it involves
going from rhythmic breathing
of inhale, inhale,
inhale, exhale, that is,
relying on the pre-Botzinger
complex neurons,
to reliance on the parafacial
nucleus neurons and box
breathing, just to give
away what's probably
already obvious, as you inhale,
hold, exhale, hold, and repeat.
And that pattern of
breathing, even though it's
rhythmic in nature because
inhales precede exhales precede
inhales and so on, there's
a deliberate breath hold
inserted there.
So anytime we're taking
conscious control
of our breathing, the parafacial
nucleus is getting involved.
Now, you don't have to assume
that the parafacial nucleus is
the only way in which we
take conscious control
of our breathing.
We can also take control of
the pre-Botzinger complex.
You can do that right now.
So for instance,
you are breathing
in some specific pattern
now that, unless you're
speaking or eating, no doubt
is going to involve inhales
followed by exhales.
But you could, for
instance, decide
that, yes, inhales are active
and exhales are passive.
But now you're going to make
the exhales active as well.
So rather than just inhale and
then let your lungs deflate,
you could inhale [INHALES]
and then force the air out.
[EXHALES] That's going to
represent a conscious taking
over of control of the
pre-Botzinger complex.
And so the reason I'm giving
this mechanistic detail is, A,
it's super important if you
want to understand all the tools
related to breathing.
B, it's actually a
pretty simple system.
Even though the areas
have fancy names
like pre-Botzinger
or parafacial,
it's pretty straightforward.
You have one area that
controls rhythmic breathing--
inhale follows exhales-- and the
other area which gets involved
in breathing any time
you start doubling up
on inhales or exhales.
In fact, the parafacial
nucleus is the one
that you're relying on
while you speak in order
to make sure that you
still get enough oxygen.
It's also the one
that you will use
if you incorporate the
physiological sigh or box
breathing.
And, frankly, most
of the time, you're
using both of these circuits
or these brain systems,
parafacial and
pre-Botzinger, in parallel.
Again, biology loves
parallel systems,
especially for
things that are so
critical that if we didn't
do them, we would die,
like breathing.
And so it makes sense that
we have two different brain
structures that control this.
So now you have an understanding
of the mechanical control
of breathing, that is,
the different parts
within the parts list that
are involved in breathing,
everything from nose to mouth
to alveoli, the lungs, et
cetera, and the muscles
involved in moving the lungs.
You understand, I like to think,
a bit about bringing oxygen
in and removing carbon dioxide
but not so much carbon dioxide
that you can't actually use
the oxygen that you have.
And you know about
two brain centers,
one controlling rhythmic
breathing and one that
controls nonrhythmic breathing.
I want to repeat something that
I said a little bit earlier
as well, which is that
breathing is incredible
because it represents
the interface
between conscious and
subconscious control
over your not just body,
not just your lungs,
but that how you breathe
influences your brain state.
So by using your
brain consciously
to control your breathing,
you are using your brain
to control your brain.
The best way I've ever
heard this described
was from a beautiful,
I should say now
classic paper in The Journal
of Physiology, published
in 1988 from
Balestrino and Somjen,
where the final line of
their summary intro states,
"The brain, by
regulating breathing,
controls its own excitability."
And just to remind
those of you that
don't remember what
excitability is,
excitability is the threshold
at which a given neuron, nerve
cell can be active or not.
So when we breathe a certain
way, the neurons of our brain
are more likely to get engaged.
They're more likely
to be active.
And when we breathe
in other ways,
our brain becomes
harder to activate.
Its excitability is reduced.
Now, you might think
excitability is a great thing.
You always want your
brain to be excitable.
But that's actually
not the case.
And, in fact, that
very statement
that Balestrino
and Somjen made led
to a number of
other investigations
that were really
important in defining
how if people
overbreathe, that is,
if they hyperventilate, at
rest, they expel, that is, they
exhale too much
carbon dioxide, what
that classic paper by
Balestrino and Somjen led to
was a number of
different investigations
in humans looking at how
different patterns of breathing
impact the overall state of
the brain and the ability
of the brain to
respond to certain what
are called sensory stimuli.
Keep in mind that your
brain is always active.
The neurons are firing at low
level, low level, low level.
But when you see something
or hear something,
or you want to
focus on something,
or you want to exercise or
really listen to something
or learn, certain
circuits in your brain
need to be more active
than everything else.
That is, there needs to
be really high what's
called signal to noise.
There's always a lot of noise
and chatter in the background,
just like the chatter
at a cocktail party
or at a stadium event.
In order to really pay
attention, focus, learn,
all the incredible things
that the brain can do,
you need that signal
to get above the noise.
There's a beautiful
paper that asks,
how does the pattern of
breathing, in particular, how
does overbreathing, change
the patterns of activity
in the brain?
This is a paper
entitled "Effects
of Voluntary Hyperventilation
on Cortical Sensory Responses."
And I will provide a link to
the study in the show note
captions.
It's a somewhat
complicated paper
if you look at all
the detailed analyzes.
However, the takeaway from this
paper is exquisitely simple
and I also believe
incredibly important.
Basically, what it
showed is that when
people hyperventilate,
they expel, that is,
they exhale more carbon dioxide
than they would normally.
So they become what's
called hypocapnic, OK?
Carbon dioxide levels
are low in the blood.
And over a short
period of time, they
become low in the
tissues of the body.
When that carbon
dioxide level drops low,
you would say, OK,
well, you're still
bringing in a lot of
oxygen, because these people
are hyperventilating.
So they should
feel really alert.
And, indeed, that's
what happens.
The people feel very alert.
However, because
they're not bringing
enough carbon dioxide in
or, rather, the proper way
to say it would be because
they're overbreathing,
exhaling too much, they are
not retaining or keeping
in enough carbon dioxide.
Well, then that lack
of carbon dioxide
means that the oxygen
that they are breathing in
can't be liberated
from the hemoglobin,
can't get to the brain.
And what they observe
is about a 30% to 40%
reduction in the
amount of oxygen that's
being delivered to the brain.
And the reduction
in carbon dioxide
also prevents some of the
normal patterns of vasodilation,
the dilating, the opening
up of the capillaries,
so, again, less blood flow.
But most importantly, as
it's shown in this paper,
the brain overall
becomes hyperexcitable.
It's as if it's being starved
of oxygen and blood flow.
And all the neurons in
a very nonspecific way
start increasing
their firing levels.
So the background activity
is getting louder and louder.
It's like the rumble or the
noise of a crowd at a stadium.
And as a consequence, the
sensory input from a sound
or from a touch or from some
other event in the world
doesn't get above the noise.
What this means is that
when we hyperventilate,
because we aren't retaining
enough carbon dioxide,
we are not getting enough
oxygen to the tissues
that need oxygen. And as a
consequence of that, the brain
becomes hyperexcitable.
We actually know that there's
an increase in anxiety.
And we become less
good, less efficient
at detecting things
in our environment.
So we're not processing
information as well at all.
The noise goes up, and
the signal goes down.
Again, incredibly
important set of findings.
I should also mention
that hyperventilation
is one way that, in
the laboratory anyway
or in neurosurgery
units for some time,
physicians would evoke seizure
in seizure-prone patients.
The reason that works is
exactly the explanation
I just gave you.
Seizure is a excitability
of the brain, not enough
inhibition or suppression
of the overall circuitry.
So you get these waves or these
storms of electrical activity.
Low levels of carbon
dioxide in the brain because
of low levels of carbon
dioxide in the blood
are one of the major
triggers for seizures.
Now, I realize that most
people listening to this
are not epileptic.
But nonetheless, this
brings us all back
to this question of what is
normal healthy breathing.
As I mentioned before,
normal healthy breathing
is breathing about six
liters of air per minute.
But of course, most
of us don't think
in terms of liters
of air, and we're not
going to measure our lung
capacity, at least most of us
aren't going to do that.
Basically, if you are taking
relatively shallow breaths
and you're just sitting there
working or maybe even walking
slowly, again, not
talking or engaging
in any kind of speech
or eating, chances
are six liters of air per minute
is about 12 shallowish breaths.
And when I say
shallow, I don't mean
breathing [INHALES SHALLOWLY]
like a little bunny
rabbit or something like that.
I just mean casually
breathing in out, in out.
The studies that have explored
the breathing patterns
in large populations of
individuals who are not
suffering necessarily from
any one specific ailment
have shown that most
people breathe far too much
per minute, that
they're engaging
in anywhere from
15 to 20 or even 30
shallow breaths per minute.
So they are vastly
overbreathing relative to how
they should be breathing.
Now, of course, if you
breathe more deeply,
so you take a vigorous
inhale [INHALES]
and then you expel
that air, well,
then to get six liters of air
into your system per minute,
you're probably only going to
need somewhere between four
and six breaths in order to
get that six liters per minute.
Now, the total
time that it takes
to do that inhale and exhale
isn't that much longer
than a shallow breath, provided
you're not deliberately
breathing quickly during
those shallow breaths.
So then you say, well, how is
it that normal healthy breathing
that delivers the appropriate
amount of carbon dioxide
into the system
and doesn't expel,
doesn't exhale too
much carbon dioxide--
how are we supposed to
do that normal breathing?
Are you supposed to
breathe four times
and then hold your breath
until the minute passes?
No.
What you find is that the
correct pattern of breathing
is going to involve two things.
First of all, nasal breathing,
because of the resistance
it provides through the nose
that we talked about earlier,
is going to deliver more
oxygen into your system.
You're going to be able
to generate more air
pressure to fill your lungs.
That greater air pressure is
going to take longer to exhale.
So already we're increasing
the amount of time
that each breath
is going to take.
And also what you find
is that people that
are breathing in the proper
healthy manner, that is,
that are balancing
oxygen and carbon
dioxide in the
proper ways, are also
taking pauses between breaths.
This is extremely important.
Because even though we
have a brain center,
the pre-Botzinger complex, that
can control or, I should say,
does control inhale-exhale
rhythmic breathing,
those pauses between breaths
are not always present
and, in fact, often
are not present
from people's baseline
breathing patterns.
As a consequence,
they overbreathe.
And as I told you before,
when people overbreathe,
their brain becomes
hyperexcitable
at the level of the
background noise.
And yet they are less efficient
at detecting and learning
information.
We'll get into the
specific studies
that really illustrate the
learning aspect a bit later.
But they are less efficient
at detecting and learning
information, at focusing,
and so on as a consequence
of this overbreathing
and the hyperexcitability
that it causes.
Now, of course, that's
also just emphasizing
the effects of
overbreathing and lack
of carbon dioxide on the brain.
There are hundreds,
if not thousands
of studies showing that when
we don't have enough carbon
dioxide in the
tissues of our body,
that's also problematic for
all the tissues-- the liver,
the lungs themselves, the
stomach, et cetera-- that
relate largely to shifts
in pH because of the fact
that carbon dioxide
strongly regulates
the acidity, alkalinity of
the blood and the tissues
that that blood
supplies nutrients to,
including carbon dioxide.
So the basic
takeaway here is you
want to breathe in a
healthy manner at rest.
And the best way to do that
is to spend some time--
and it doesn't take much,
maybe a minute or so each day--
paying attention to how quickly
you are breathing per minute
when you are simply at rest,
when you're making coffee
in the morning, when you're
sitting down to read,
when you're on social media.
Chronically holding
your breath isn't good
but neither is overbreathing.
And, again, every study that has
examined the typical patterns
of breathing and
patterns of breathing
that show up as
normal and abnormal
has found that more
often than not,
during the nighttime,
people are underbreathing.
And in the daytime,
they are overbreathing.
They're hyperventilating.
I'd like to just
take a brief moment
and thank one of our
podcast sponsors, which
is InsideTracker.
InsideTracker is a
personalized nutrition platform
that analyzes data
from your blood and DNA
to better understand your body
and help you reach your health
goals.
I've long been a believer in
getting regular blood work done
for the simple reason that blood
work is the only way that you
can monitor the markers, such
as hormone markers, lipids,
metabolic factors, et
cetera, that impact
your immediate and
long-term health.
One major challenge
with blood work,
however, is that
most of the time, it
does not come back with
any information about what
to do in order to move
the values for hormones,
metabolic factors, lipids,
et cetera, into the ranges
that you want.
With InsideTracker,
changing those values
becomes very straightforward
because it has a personalized
dashboard that you
can use to address
the nutrition-based,
behavior-based,
supplement-based approaches
that you can use in order
to move those values
into the ranges that
are optimal for you, your
vitality, and your longevity.
InsideTracker now
includes a measurement
of apolipoprotein B, so-called
apoB, in their ultimate plan.
AboB is a key marker of
cardiovascular health,
and therefore,
there's extreme value
to knowing your apoB levels.
If you'd like to
try InsideTracker,
you can go to
InsideTracker.com/Huberman
to get 20% off any of
InsideTracker's plans.
Again, that's
InsideTracker.com/Huberman
to get 20% off.
So next, I'd like
to address what
you can do about your normal
patterns of breathing,
that is, how you or
anyone can adjust
their normal patterns of
breathing from an unhealthy
to an unhealthy state.
But the first thing we
have to do, of course,
is determine whether
or not you're already
breathing in an unhealthy
or in a healthy way.
And, again, when I say
healthy or unhealthy, I mean,
are you overbreathing?
Are you underbreathing?
Are you delivering
the appropriate ratios
of oxygen and carbon
dioxide to the tissues
of your brain and body?
In order to do this, we're
going to do a simple test.
Again, please
don't do this while
driving or operating heavy
machinery or near water
of any kind.
But assuming that you're not
doing any of those things,
I encourage you to
sit down, certainly
not lie down but just sit down.
I suppose you also
could do it standing.
And we are going to do what's
called the carbon dioxide
tolerance test.
The carbon dioxide
tolerance test
is a sort of back
of the envelope
measure of how well you are
managing carbon dioxide,
that is, how well you can
control your breathing
at both the mechanical
and the chemical level.
It's a very simple test.
What you're going to do
is for the next 10 seconds
or so while I'm speaking, you're
just going to breathe normally.
Now, again and again
throughout this episode,
I'm going to encourage you to
be a nasal breather whenever
possible.
But of course, there are
instances in which you
want to engage mouth breathing.
But for the time
being, as I continue
to blab on for the
next few seconds,
just inhale through your nose,
exhale through your nose.
You don't have to deliberately
slow your breathing
or increase the cadence
of your breathing.
However, in that
time, you're also
going to want to find some
sort of time measuring
device, like could be your phone
or it could be a stopwatch.
What I'm going to ask you
to do in a few minutes
is I'm going to ask you to
inhale through your nose
as deeply as you possibly can.
That is, you're going to fill
your lungs as much as you
can through your nose.
And then start a
timer and measure
how long it takes for you
to deliberately control
that exhale until
your lungs are empty.
So this is going to
be a controlled exhale
through the nose after
a big deep breath.
But for the time
being, keep breathing
at a kind of calm,
regular cadence.
So you can find that time
measuring device now,
or you can come back to
it later if you like.
When I say inhale, you're going
to inhale as deeply as you can
through your nose, remembering
that the diaphragm can really
help you here to get a
deep inhale by having
your belly move out
while you inhale.
And then when I
say start, you're
going to measure the
time that it takes to do
a complete lungs empty exhale.
In fact, I'll
measure it for you.
This will be one of the rare
instances in this podcast
where there's going to be
a long period of silence
as I measure something.
So I've got a stopwatch here.
So please prepare to do the big
inhale and start inhaling now.
So inhale as deeply as
you can through your nose.
Fill your lungs as
much as you can.
OK?
Now start, meaning
slowly control the exhale
through your nose.
You're trying to let that air
out as slowly as possible.
And I'm just going to call out
every 10 or 15 seconds or so.
And you want to note when
your lungs are empty.
I know you can hold your
breath with your lungs empty.
That is not an accurate measure.
15 seconds.
It is important that when
note your lungs are empty
and that you're trying to
control the exhale as much
as possible so that you don't
arrive at that lungs empty time
too quickly.
I'll explain what
too quickly means.
30 seconds.
OK, for those of you that have
already reached lungs empty,
please go back to
breathing normally.
For those of you
that haven't, you
can hang in here a little
longer if you're still
discarding that air.
45 seconds.
And we're rounding toward
a minute, not quite there.
Some of you are probably
still letting out that air.
I want to point out
none of this has
to do with cardiovascular
fitness level, at least
not in any kind of direct way.
And 60 seconds.
And I realize there will
be a small subset of you
out there that are
still expelling
your air in a slow lungs--
slow exhale manner
through the nose.
OK, so what we just did is a
back of the envelope carbon
dioxide discard rate if
you need to pause this
and go back and try
it again you just
want to time how
long it takes you
to go from lungs full
to lungs empty, again,
with the full understanding I
know that you can all sit there
like beasts and hold your
breath with your lungs empty.
But please don't do that
because that's not going
has been informative for
what I'm telling you now.
What I'm going to
tell you now is
that if it took you 20 seconds
or less to expel all your air,
that is, you couldn't
extend that exhale longer
than 20 seconds, in a kind
of back of the envelope way,
we can say that have a
relatively brief or low carbon
dioxide tolerance.
If it took you somewhere between
25 and 40, maybe 45 seconds
to expel all your
air, that is, you
could control that exhale for
about 45 seconds or 30 seconds,
then you have a moderate level
of carbon dioxide tolerance.
And if, for instance, you
were able to go 50 seconds
or longer for that discard
until you hit lungs empty,
you have a fairly high degree
of carbon dioxide tolerance.
Now, here's the deal.
If you had low carbon
dioxide tolerance, that
is, you're 20 seconds
or less, you're
going to write down
the number three.
If you had moderate levels
of carbon dioxide tolerance,
you're going to write
down the number five.
or you could even
put five to six.
And then if you are in
that bracket of people
that was able to discard your
air over a period of 50 seconds
or more, you're going to
write down the number 8 to 10.
OK?
Now, what are these numbers?
What are we talking about?
And before we get into what
to do with these numbers,
I want to emphasize
again, this does not
have to do with
fitness level per se.
I know some world
class triathletes
that have very fast carbon
dioxide blow-off times.
That is, their discard rates
are 20 seconds or less.
I should also point out that
if you're very stressed,
that number is going
to be very small.
If you're very relaxed,
like you just woke up
after a long night of
sleep and you feel great,
that number is going
to be extended.
So this is a back of
the envelope measure
that you're going
to use each time you
decide to do the
exercise I'm going
to tell you about in a moment.
And the exercise I'm going
to tell you about in a moment
can be done every
day if you like.
But what the most interesting
studies, at least to me,
indicate is that you
could do the exercise
I'll tell you about even
just once or twice a week
and greatly improve your
efficiency of breathing
and shift yourself away from
overbreathing when at rest,
even if you're not
thinking about how
you're breathing at rest.
So what is this exercise?
Well, you just got your number,
either low, medium, or high
bracket number for carbon
dioxide discard rate.
Remember, if you're in the low
category, your number is three.
If you're medium,
it's five to six.
And if you are in the
long carbon dioxide
discard rate, long
duration carbon
dioxide discard rate, that
is, 8 to 10 is your number.
Now you're going to do two
minutes of what most people
would call box breathing.
What is box breathing?
Box breathing are equal
duration inhale, hold,
exhale, hold, repeat.
So inhale, hold, exhale, hold.
Sounds very easy, right?
How long do you inhale and then
hold, exhale and then hold?
Well, you now know.
If you are in the low group of
carbon dioxide discard rate,
your inhale is going to be
three seconds, your hold will
be three seconds, your
exhale will be three seconds,
and then you repeat,
three seconds.
So each side of the
box, if you will,
is going to be
three seconds long.
If you were in the moderate
carbon dioxide discard rate
category, then you're going to
inhale for five to six seconds,
hold for five to six,
exhale for five to six,
hold for five to six, repeat
for about two minutes.
You could do three
minutes if you want.
But I think it's important
to have protocols that
are feasible for most people.
And that's going to mean
doing things for about two
to five minutes when it comes
to these breath rehabilitation
exercises for restoring
normal breathing.
And then, of course, if you are
in the long category of carbon
dioxide discard rate, you
should be able to do an 8 to 10
second inhale, 8 to 10 second
hold, 8 to 10 second exhale, 8
to 10 second hold, and repeat.
So you could do
that exercise now
if you like, or you could
do it at some point offline.
You can pause this podcast
if you want and go try it.
That's an exercise
that you can do
for about two to three minutes
once or twice per week.
What's happening when
you do that exercise?
Well, first of all,
you are greatly
increasing your neuromechanical
control over the diaphragm.
This is very important.
Most people are not aware
of this phrenic nerve
pathway in the diaphragm.
And you are greatly increasing
your mechanical control
over this pathway
through the process
we call neuroplasticity.
When you deliberately focus on
a aspect of your nervous system
control and particular nervous
system control over musculature
that normally is subconscious
and you're not paying attention
to and when you actively
take control of that,
it requires that your
brain adjust and rewire
the relationship between
the different components
of that circuit.
And the wonderful
thing is that has
been shown to lead to changes
in your resting pattern
of breathing.
Now, why did we go
through the whole business
of doing the carbon
dioxide tolerance test?
Well, for people who don't
tolerate carbon dioxide very
well, they don't have
very good phrenic,
that is, neuromechanical
control of the diaphragm,
for whatever reason-- again,
it doesn't mean you're not fit.
It just means you don't have
or you have not yet developed
neuromechanical control
of the diaphragm.
It would be near
impossible for you
to do box breathing for two
or three minutes with eight
seconds in, eight seconds
hold, eight seconds exhale,
eight second hold.
So that's why we
do a test to see
what you're capable of doing.
You don't want the box breathing
to be too strained where you're
[GRUNTS],, where you're
really challenged
to get around the whole box.
You want it to be relatively
easy because, remember,
you're trying to translate this
pattern to your normal pattern
of breathing, that is,
your pattern of breathing
when you're not consciously
thinking about breathing.
And what are we
really translating
when we do this box
breathing type exercise?
What you're translating
is the ability
to pause between
breaths and yet take
full mechanically-driven breaths
that involve the phrenic nerve
and diaphragm.
So, again, you're
encouraging, especially
if you use nasal breathing
when you do the box breathing--
you're encouraging phrenic
control over the diaphragm.
And you're getting that six
liters of air per minute
or so using fewer and
fewer breaths over time.
So this is a, again,
zero cost-- although it
does cost a little bit of
time-- zero cost approach
to adjusting your normal pattern
of breathing at rest, which
has a huge number of
positive outcomes in terms
of your ability to stay
relatively calm, to not
get the hyperexcitability
of the brain.
It has actually been
shown in various studies--
and we'll talk about one
in particular later--
to greatly improve not
just levels of calm
and reduce bouts of stress but
also improve nighttime sleep.
There are huge
number of benefits
that can come from doing
this box breathing exercise.
But you got to get the duration
of the size of the box right,
and that's why you do the
carbon dioxide tolerance test.
One thing that
many people notice
after doing the carbon dioxide
tolerance test even just once
and then doing this box
breathing exercise once
or twice a week is that after
two or three weeks, the box
breathing itself
becomes very easy.
And in that case, I recommend
taking the carbon dioxide
tolerance test over again.
And almost always
what you'll find
is that you have been
able to extend your carbon
dioxide discard rate,
and therefore, you now
fall into a different category,
not just the lower medium
but the long carbon dioxide
discard rate category,
and you are able to extend
the duration of those inhale,
hold, exhale, holds
during the box breathing.
And, of course, the
ultimate benefit of all this
is that it translates to
deeper and yet less frequent
breathing when at rest and
when not consciously paying
attention to how you're
breathing during the daytime.
Again, if at all possible,
do all of this breathing
through the nose.
For those of you that have
a severely occluded nose,
the recommendation always is to
breathe through your nose more.
But I do realize
that for some people,
it's really uncomfortable
to breathe through the nose
because they have such an
occluded nasal pathway.
And for you folks, doing
some of this breathing
through the mouth
can probably suffice.
But if at all possible, do the
breathing through the nose.
And please also let me know how
your progress evolves over time
with the carbon dioxide discard
rate and the box breathing.
And of course, the
positive shifts
that occur in normal
unconscious daytime breathing
translate to all
the opposite things
that we talked about when
you are overbreathing
during the daytime.
So what I just described in
terms of the carbon dioxide
tolerance test and the
exercise using box breathing
to restore normal
patterns of breathing
and not overbreathe and
therefore not eliminate
too much carbon
dioxide is exactly
the two tests that were
incorporated into a study
that my laboratory
did in collaboration
with our associate
chair of psychiatry
at Stanford School of Medicine,
Dr. David Spiegel, who's
also been a guest on
this podcast previously.
And that study
explored box breathing.
But it also explored
other forms of breathing
and actually compared those
forms of deliberate breathing
to meditation as
a means to explore
what are going to be the
minimal effective doses and most
effective ways to chronically
reduce stress around the clock
and improve mood
and improve sleep.
So the study I'm referring to
was just published recently.
It's entitled "Brief Structured
Respiration Practices Enhance
Mood and Reduce
Physiological Arousal."
We will also provide a link
to this paper in the show note
captions.
What this study
really focused on
was a simple question, which is,
what is the shortest and most
effective practice that
people can use in order
to reduce their levels of stress
not just during that breathwork
practice or meditation practice
but around the clock, 24
hours a day, including
improvements in sleep?
And we were excited to do this
study because many studies had
explored how meditation
or, in some cases,
fewer studies have
explored how breathwork
can impact different brain
states or bodily states.
But very few studies had
explored how those breathwork
or meditation practices
influenced body-brain states
around the clock
when people were not
performing the particular
meditation or breathwork
practice.
The reason we were
able to do this study
was really fortunate.
The folks over at WHOOP
were generous enough
to donate a bunch of
WHOOP straps, which
allowed us to measure
heart rate variability,
a number of other different
physiological parameters.
We also got subjective
reports about people's mood
and feelings of well-being.
We got data about their
sleep pinged to us
from remote locations.
So these people, rather than
being brought to the laboratory
and being in a very artificial
circumstance, the laboratory,
as much as we like to
think our laboratory
is realistic-- we
have virtual reality
and things like
that-- there's nothing
as realistic as the real world.
And so we were able
to have more than a
hundred subjects out in the real
world living their real lives
pinging back to us data all
the time, 24 hours a day
so that we could measure how
their different interventions
that we asked them to
do, breathwork practices
or meditation practices,
were impacting
physiological parameters.
And they were also
informing us regularly
about their subjective
mood, et cetera.
We got a lot of data,
as you can imagine.
And the basic takeaway
from the study was twofold.
First of all, we discovered that
deliberate breathwork practices
done for about five
minutes per day
across the course
of about a month led
to greater reductions in stress
than did a five minute a day
meditation practice.
Now, that is not to say that
meditation is not useful.
In fact, there are dozens,
if not hundreds, of papers,
including one
particular, I should
say, particularly beautiful
study from Wendy Suzuki's lab
at New York University showing
that a daily 10 to 13 minute
mindfulness meditation practice
can greatly improve focus,
memory, and a number of other
things related to cognition
and learning.
However, the research
on meditation
has shown us that meditation,
at least short meditations,
mainly lead to improvements
in focus and memory,
not so much reductions in
stress, although they do
lead to reductions in stress.
What we found was that any
number of different breathwork
practices-- and we
explored three--
done for five minutes a
day outperformed meditation
in terms of the
ability of breathwork
to reduce stress around the
clock compared to meditation.
The three types of breathwork
that we explored also
showed different effects.
I should mention the
three types of breathwork
that we compared were
box breathing of the sort
that you just learned about.
We compare that to something
called cyclic sighing, which
involves two inhales
through the nose
to get maximally inflated lungs
followed by a long exhale.
I'll return to that in a moment.
That was repeated
for five minutes
at a time for each session.
And a third breathwork
practice, which
was cyclic hyperventilation,
which, as the name suggests,
involves people inhaling
deeply through the nose,
then exhaling passively
through the mouth,
and then repeating
inhale through the nose,
exhale through the
mouth, repeating
that for 25 cycles, one cycle
being an inhale and an exhale.
So that equals one cycle.
Repeating that for 25 cycles,
then exhaling all their air
and holding their
breath with lungs
empty for about
15 to 30 seconds,
and then repeating inhale,
exhale, cyclic hyperventilation
for the duration
of five minutes.
So people were divided into
these different groups,
either mindfulness
meditation where they sat,
they were not told to
control their breathing
in any specific way.
They closed their eyes.
They focused their
attention on a region
just behind their forehead.
One group did that.
The other group
did cyclic sighing.
Another group did box breathing.
Another group did
cyclic hyperventilation.
As any sort of clinical
trial like this ought to,
we then swapped people
into different groups.
So they served as
their own control.
So we could evaluate
any between and within
individual variability.
Again, there are a lot
of data in this paper.
But the takeaway was that for
the sake of stress reduction
around the clock and for
the sake of improving sleep
and mood, the most
effective practice
of the four practices
that we examined
was the cyclic sighing.
Again, cyclic sighing is
performed the following way.
You inhale through the
nose as deeply as you can.
Then you do a second inhale
immediately afterwards to try
and maximally inflate the lungs.
In fact, that's what happens.
We know that during
that second inhale,
even if it's just a very
sharp, short inhale,
the extra physical
vigor that's required
to generate that
second inhale causes
those alveoli of the lungs,
which may have collapsed--
and, indeed, in between
breaths and often even just
through the course of
the day and especially
if we get stressed, those
alveoli of the lungs
start to collapse.
And because they're
damp on the inside--
they have a little bit of fluid.
They're like a balloon
with a little bit
of fluid in the middle.
It takes a little
bit of physical force
to pop those open.
Now, you're not literally
exploding them pop.
But you're reinflating
them with air.
And then you perform the
long exhale through the mouth
until lungs are empty.
So it looks exactly like this.
[INHALES DEEPLY]
[INHALES SHARPLY]
[EXHALES]
Now, we know that one
single physiological sigh
of the sort that
I just described
performed at any time of
day under any conditions,
whether or not you're about to
walk on stage to give a talk
or you're in a meeting and
you're feeling stressed,
or you're in a conversation
that's very stressful,
or you can feel stress mounting
because you're in traffic
or any number of psychological
or physical stressors
that may be approaching
you or you feel
are oppressing you, doing one
physiological sigh of the sort
that I just described is
the fastest physiologically
verified way that we
are aware of to reduce
your levels of stress and to
reintroduce calm, that is,
to shift your autonomic
nervous system
from a state of heightened
levels of autonomic arousal.
That is, sympathetic nervous
system as, it's called,
is at a higher activation
level than the so-called
parasympathetic nervous system.
Again, sympathetic nervous
system having nothing
to do with sympathy,
has everything
to do with so-called
fight or flight,
although it controls
other things,
too, including positive arousal.
And the parasympathetic
nervous system,
often referred to as the
rest and digest system,
although it does
other things, too,
is associated with calming.
Those two things
are always in kind
of push-pull with one another,
like a seesaw or push-pull,
however you want
to think about it.
One physiological sigh,
meaning that big, deep inhale,
short second inhale
also through the nose,
and then long exhale to
completely lungs empty,
is known to restore
the level of balance
in the
sympathetic-parasympathetic
neural circuitry and
is the fastest way
to reintroduce calm.
That's one physiological sigh.
In this study, what we
asked was that people
perform that repeatedly,
so-called cyclic sighing,
for the duration
of five minutes.
And the people who did
that cyclic sighing
for five minutes a day,
regardless of the time of day
that they did it, experienced
the greatest reductions
in stress not just
during the practice
but around the 24-hour cycle.
And it translated,
again, to all sorts
of positive subjective changes--
improvements in sleep, lower
resting heart rate
at all times of day.
So this is important.
Again, this study was
not just exploring
what happens during
meditation or breathwork,
cyclic sighing, et cetera.
It was exploring how the changes
that occur during that practice
translate to
changes in breathing
and heart rate, mood, et cetera,
throughout the 24-hour cycle.
So the takeaway here is twofold.
First of all, if
you are somebody
who wants to improve
your mood and reduce
your overall levels
of stress and you only
have five minutes a
day to invest in that,
hopefully you're doing
all the other things
like trying to get proper
sleep and exercise,
social connection, nutrition,
et cetera, sunlight
in the morning, of course.
Can't leave that out.
But if you were going to
devote five minutes a day
to a stress reduction
practice that is now supported
by data to translate
to reductions in stress
around the clock,
the data say that you
would want to invest that
in cyclic sighing, that is,
double inhale through
the nose, extended exhale
through the mouth until
your lungs are empty,
then repeat for
five minutes a day.
You, of course, if you
like, could do meditation.
It still had positive
effects, meaning
it reduced stress, although
not as much as cyclic sighing.
You could do box
breathing if you
want for the purpose
of reducing stress.
All the practices we
explored did reduce stress.
But cyclic sighing performed
for five minutes a day
had the most robust
and pervasive effect
in reducing stress, improving
mood, and improving sleep.
That's the first
message of the study.
The second takeaway is that
one physiological sigh--
that's right just one
physiological sigh, where
you inhale deeply
through the nose
another inhale through the
nose to maximally inflate
the alveoli of the
lungs, and then you
exhale to completely lungs
empty and then go back
to normal breathing,
is the fastest
way to introduce a level
of calm and to reduce
your overall levels of
stress in real time.
And this is very important.
I think that out
there these days,
we hear a lot about stress
reduction techniques.
And most all of the stress
reduction techniques
that have been
explored, everything
from massage to meditation
to breathwork to a hot shower
to a foot rub,
will calm you down.
The question is, do
they calm you down just
during that practice?
Great if it does.
But does it also translate
to reduced levels
of stress at other times
in the 24-hour cycle
and other positive
effects as well?
So one physiological sigh
is a very efficient way
to adjust that ratio of
sympathetic to parasympathetic
activation and immediately
bring about calm.
So it's excellent for
real-time control of stress.
The other thing about
physiological sighs
is that it's not a hack.
It's not the application of a
breathing practice to something
that it wasn't intended for.
In fact, physiological
sighs were not
discovered by me at all.
They were discovered
by physiologists
in the 1930s, who found that
when people underbreathe,
they have a buildup of carbon
dioxide in their system.
And even though carbon
dioxide is essential for life,
you don't want too much
of it in your system.
And that people, whether or
not they were asleep or awake,
would engage a physiological
sigh spontaneously,
subconsciously.
They would do this double
inhale through the nose
and extended exhale
through the mouth.
And that did not just eliminate
excessive carbon dioxide
from the system.
It also rebalanced the
oxygen-carbon dioxide ratio
in the proper ways.
In fact, it's
observed in animals.
You might see this in
animals that are tired.
When animals or
humans get tired,
they tend to start
underbreathing a little bit,
and that can often disrupt
the balance of carbon dioxide
and oxygen. And right
before a dog will go down
for a nap, for instance,
you'll notice that it'll
do this double inhale, exhale.
people when they are sleeping,
if they hold their breath
for a period of time,
which, frankly, all of us
do periodically
throughout sleep,
they will engage a spontaneous
physiological sigh.
During the daytime, we are often
holding our breath, especially
nowadays-- and there's
a study on this
that we'll talk about a
little bit later-- where
when people text message
or they're emailing,
although nowadays people are
mainly on social media and text
messaging, they often
are holding their breath.
They will follow a breath
hold by a physiological sigh
because during that
breath hold, they're
building up the level of
carbon dioxide in their system.
Now, mind you, I spent
close to a half an hour
telling you that most people
are overbreathing at rest,
and that's also true.
But people often will
shift from overbreathing
to underbreathing, which
is a terrible pattern.
So physiological sighs done
either as a one-off, one
physiological sigh to clamp
stress or reduce stress
in real time, or repeatedly
over five minutes as a practice
that you do each day is
going to be not just the most
effective way to
approach reducing stress
around the clock and in real
time but also the one that's
highly compatible with the
way that the neural circuits
that control breathing
were designed.
The physiological sigh has some
other very useful applications.
One of the more, I would say,
useful ones, at least to those
of you that exercise,
is going to be
the use of physiological
sigh in order
to remove the
so-called side stitch.
So if you've ever been running
or swimming or exercising
and you felt a cramp
on your right side,
chances are, despite what your
high school PE coach told you,
that raising your
arms above your head
or drinking less water
before you exercise
is not going to get
rid of that cramp.
And here's why.
It's not a cramp at all.
If you recall the cervical
3, 4, and 5 nerves that
give rise to the phrenic nerve
and go down and innervate
your diaphragm, well,
as I mentioned before,
a certain number of
those nerve fibers
actually course into the
diaphragm and go up underneath.
And if you recall
earlier, I also
said that the diaphragm sits
right on top of the liver.
In other words, you actually
have a sensory innervation
of the diaphragm, the deep
diaphragm, and the liver.
And there's something called
referenced pain, which
is what people
generally experience
when they have that side stitch
on their right-hand side.
So if you're ever
exercising and you
feel a cramp on your
right-hand side,
it's possible that
it's a genuine cramp.
But more likely is the fact
that that phrenic nerve
sensory innervation is now
being carried up to your brain
and you are detecting some local
or referenced pain in the liver
and in the diaphragm.
Now, that doesn't
necessarily mean
you're doing anything wrong,
although you might not
be breathing properly for
running at that moment,
and that's what gave rise to it.
It could be some spasming
of the phrenic nerve
or some inefficient
breathing during running.
We had an entire series on
fitness with Dr. Andy Galpin.
One of those episodes
included a lot of information
on breathing.
It was the episode on
endurance, although breathing
was a topic that was thread
through multiple episodes
in that series.
You can find that series
at HubermanLab.com.
Talks a lot about how to
breathe during running,
how to breathe during
weightlifting, et cetera.
But the point for now
is that if ever you're
experiencing that
right-side side stitch,
I encourage you to perform
the physiological sigh.
And the good news is you can
perform it while still running
or while still
swimming, although I
suppose with swimming,
you might have
to make some adjustments
because, of course,
you don't want to inhale
water, or while cycling
or any type of activity.
If you perform that
physiological sigh generally
two or three times,
what will occur
is that because of
changes in the firing
of the phrenic nerve, and in
particular because of changes
in the sensory feedback
from the sensory component
of the phrenic nerve
back to the brain,
you will experience an
alleviation of the pain
from that right-side
side stitch.
In other words, you can
get rid of side cramps
doing physiological
sighs during activities,
in particular during
running activities.
Now, I should also mention that
if you're experiencing a side
stitch on the
left-side, chances are
that has to do with excessive
air or fluid in your stomach.
And there are
reasons for that that
also have to do with the way
that the phrenic nerve is--
it's bilateral and
branches to both sides
and is catching sensory input
on the left side from some
of the local organs and sensory
innervation of those organs.
But if you have
right-side side stitch,
the physiological
sigh done two or three
times while still running ought
to relieve that side stitch.
Now, as long as we're
talking about breathing
and the phrenic nerve
and the relationship
between the phrenic nerve and
your liver and your stomach
and some of the other
organs in that neighborhood,
we should talk about the
relationship between breathing
and heart rate.
This is an incredibly
important topic,
so much so that I perhaps
should have brought it up
at the beginning of the episode.
But nonetheless, you now know
what your diaphragm does.
When you inhale, your
diaphragm moves down.
That's right.
When you contract your
diaphragm, it moves down.
It creates space for
your lungs to inhale.
And when you exhale,
your diaphragm moves up.
Well, when you inhale and
your diaphragm moves down,
what happens is there's
more space created
in the thoracic cavity and
particularly if you're also
breathing deeply and you're
using those intercostal muscles
to expand your ribs.
As a consequence,
the heart actually
gets a little bit bigger.
It's a temporary
enlargement in the heart.
But it's a real enlargement.
And as a consequence,
whatever blood is in the heart
is now in a larger volume
because the heart got bigger.
And as a consequence, that
blood is moving more slowly
through that larger volume
for a short period of time.
But nonetheless, it's
moving more slowly.
Your nervous system detects
that and sends a neural signal
to the heart to speed
the heart rate up.
In other words, inhales
increase heart rate.
The opposite is true
when you exhale.
When you exhale, your
diaphragm moves up.
Your rib cage tends
to move inward a bit.
And you compact the heart.
You reduce the volume
of the heart overall.
When you reduce the volume
of the heart overall,
blood flow through
the heart accelerates
because it's a smaller volume.
So a given unit
of blood is going
to move more quickly
through that small volume.
Your nervous system detects
that and sends a signal
to slow the heart down.
So just as inhales
speed the heart up,
exhales slow your
heart rate down.
Now, of course, even though
you can double up on inhales
or even triple up on inhales,
sooner or later, if you inhale,
you're going to have to exhale.
And the converse is
also true, of course.
So what does this mean in terms
of controlling your heart rate?
Well, let's say you are
going in for a blood draw,
or you're going out on
stage and you're stressed.
Well, I would encourage you to
do a physiological sigh, maybe
two physiological sighs to
bring your level of calm up
and your level of stress down.
Nonetheless, if
you have any reason
why you want to quickly
reduce your heart rate
or accelerate your heart rate
for sake of physical work
output or to calm yourself
down additionally, not just use
the physiological
sigh, well, then you
can take advantage of this
relationship between inhales
and exhales
controlling heart rate.
If you want to increase
your heart rate,
you can simply inhale
longer and more vigorously
relative to your exhales.
And if you want to
decrease your heart rate,
well, then you're going to
make your exhales longer
and/or more vigorous
than your inhales.
In fact, this process, which
is called respiratory sinus
arrhythmia, is the basis of what
we call heart rate variability.
Heart rate variability
involves the vagus nerve,
the 10th cranial nerve, which
is a parasympathetic nerve that
is associated with
a calming aspect
of the autonomic nervous system,
slowing your heart rate down
by extending your exhales.
And it really forms the basis
of most all breathing practices.
If you look at any
breathing practices,
whether or not it's Wim Hof
breathing, Tummo breathing,
Kundalini breathing,
Pranayama breathing,
physiological sighing, cyclic
sighing, and on and on and on,
if you were to measure the
ratio of inhales to exhales
and the vigor of inhales to
exhales, what you would find
is that each one would create a
net increase or a net decrease
in heart rate that could be very
accurately predicted by whether
or not that breathing practice
emphasized inhales, emphasized
exhales, or had those two
features, inhale and exhale,
be of equal duration
and intensity.
In fact, if you wanted to
equilibrate your heart rate,
what you would do is you
would do box breathing
because inhale,
hold, exhale, hold
is, by definition, creating
equal duration inhales
and exhales of essentially
equivalent vigor.
When you do a
physiological sigh,
you're doing two
big inhales, which
is going the speed
your heart rate up
just a little bit, but then
a long extended exhale.
The exhale in the end is much
longer than the two inhales
even when combined.
And so you get a net decrease in
heart rate, the calming effect.
And then practices such as Tummo
breathing or Wim Hof breathing
or cyclic hyperventilation,
[HYPERVENTILATES] deep inhales
and exhales, the inhales
are more vigorous compared
to the more passive
exhales-- are
going to lead to
increases in heart rate.
So the relationship between
breathing and heart rate
is an absolutely lockstep
one where your heart
rate follows your breathing.
Your heart rate
and your breathing
are in an intimate
discussion with one another,
but where always and
forever your inhales
increase your heart rate,
your exhales decrease it.
Now, this feature,
which physicians
call respiratory
sinus arrhythmia,
or we sometimes hear about more
often nowadays as heart rate
variability, is something
that people in sport
have known about for
a very long time.
It's why, for instance, that
marksmen will exhale just prior
to taking a shot.
That's particularly
true for people
that compete in the biathlon,
where they cross country ski.
So their heart rate
is up, up, up, up, up.
Then they'll get to the
point where they actually
have to shoot a target,
and they'll exhale,
and then they'll
shoot the target.
This is also why, for instance,
if you want to bring your heart
rate down very quickly between
rounds of martial arts,
there are a number of
different ways to do that.
But an extended exhale of any
kind or, frankly, any breathing
practice that emphasizes
exhales is going
to bring your heart rate down.
This has been incorporated in
a number of different contexts,
including sport, military.
It's also now being incorporated
in a clinical context
for people who feel a
panic attack coming on.
I'm very gratified to learn that
the physiological sigh is now
being explored as a tool
to prevent panic attacks
and anxiety attacks.
This is prior to the
panic attack, people
bringing their heart
rate down, again,
through those extended exhales.
So learning to
extend your exhale
is really a terrific
skill to master,
and it's a very easy
skill to master, frankly.
Why do I say a skill?
Well, remember what
I said earlier,
which is that humans
inhale actively
and most typically
will passively exhale,
just let the air [EXHALES] drop
out of them at whatever rate,
depending on how much
air they inhaled.
Actively exhaling, that is,
actively relaxing the diaphragm
and actively relaxing
those intercostal muscles
of the chest, those ones
that are, I should say,
between the ribs,
is a skill that you
can very quickly
acquire and will
allow you to use
that relationship
between the phrenic nerve,
the diaphragm, and the size
of the heart, the heart
volume, and all that stuff
to really take control
of heart rate quickly.
So that if you feel like your
heart is racing too much--
and, frankly, a
lot of people have
a lot of what's called
interoceptive awareness,
especially anxious people.
They can really
sense what's going on
in their body, other
people less so.
Like, oh my god,
my heart's beating.
It's ready to jump out of my
chest, and I don't like that.
I don't like that.
[EXHALES] Big, long exhale.
It doesn't matter if you do it
through the nose or the mouth.
Big, long exhale is
going to allow you
to slow your heart rate down.
Let's talk about hiccups.
Everybody experiences
hiccups from time to time.
I think most people would
agree that one hiccup is
sort of funny.
Two hiccups in a
row is really funny.
And three hiccups
in a row is where
it starts to be concerning,
in part because hiccups
can be kind of painful.
You can experience pain in
your gut or your lower abdomen
and sometimes in
your chest as well.
And it feels kind of intrusive.
It gets in the way of
having conversation or just
sitting there and relaxing.
Fortunately, there's a simple
way to get rid of hiccups.
And you can arrive at
that simple technique
if you understand a
little bit about what
gives rise to hiccups.
The reason we get
hiccups at all is
because we experience a
spasm of the phrenic nerve.
The phrenic nerve,
as you recall,
is a nerve that emanates
from the cervical region,
to be specific C3, 4, and 5.
Those spinal nerves go down,
of course, behind the heart
and innervate the
diaphragm, which
is the muscle that when it
contracts, it moves down
and allows the lungs to fill.
And then when you
relax the diaphragm,
then the diaphragm moves
up, and the lungs shrink
or they expel air,
so-called exhalation.
Now, the phrenic nerve also
has that sensory branch.
So it's not just involved
in controlling the diaphragm
at the motor level.
It's also sensing things
deep within the diaphragm
and in the liver as well
because the liver sits right
below the diaphragm.
So a hiccup has that
painful sensation from time
to time because there's
a rapid sensory feedback
or a signal, rather, of a
sharp sensation of contraction
within the diaphragm.
And that's relayed
back to the brain.
And you consciously perceive
that as a little bit of pain.
And then, of course, the
hiccup is [HICCUPS] the hiccup,
which is the spasming
of the phrenic nerve
that you experience more
or less in your throat.
But all this really is happening
along the phrenic nerve
and toward the diaphragm.
What this all means
is that if you
can stop the phrenic nerve from
spasming, you can stop hiccups.
There are a lot of
approaches that people
have tried to take to eliminate
spasming of the phrenic nerve.
You'll hear that breathing
into a bag, which
is one way to reingest or
reinhale carbon dioxide that
otherwise would be expelled out
into the environment, can help.
That's a very indirect method.
It rarely works, frankly,
because it really
has to do more with
adjusting your breathing
to try and adjust the
activity of the phrenic nerve.
It's a really roundabout way
of trying to alleviate hiccups.
Some people will
experience relief
from drinking from
a glass of water
from the opposite
side of the glass.
So you have to tilt
over at the waist.
It's a kind of messy approach.
Again, it doesn't tend to
work a lot of the time.
For some people, it
works every time.
But for most people,
it doesn't work at all.
However, there is
a technique that
can reliably eliminate hiccups.
And it's a technique that takes
advantage of hypercontracting
the phrenic nerve over
a short period of time
so that it then subsequently
relaxes or alleviates
the spasming of
the phrenic nerve.
And that simple method is to
inhale three times in a row.
This is a very unusual
pattern of breathing.
But what it involves is
taking a big, deep inhale
through your nose.
Then before you exhale any
air, take a second inhale
through the nose, however
brief that inhale might be,
and then a third even micro
or millisecond long inhale
through your nose to
get that third inhale.
And then hold your breath
for about 15 to 20 seconds,
and then slowly exhale.
So even though I'm not
experiencing any hiccups
right now.
I will demonstrate the method
for eliminating hiccups
so that you're all
clear on how to do it.
OK, here I go.
[INHALES DEEPLY]
[INHALES]
[EXHALES]
OK, so it's three inhales
all through the nose.
And it is true that that
second and third inhale
takes some physical
effort to really get
additional air into the
lungs without exhaling first.
It feels like-- the only
way I can describe it really
is as a sharp second
and third inhale
because you really
have to engage
the musculature of those
intercostal muscles
and the diaphragm
in order to do it.
And then that long exhale can be
through the nose or the mouth.
But I find it particularly
relaxing or even pleasant to do
it through the nose.
This method of three inhales
through the nose followed
by a long exhale through
the nose or mouth
will eliminate hiccups right
away because what it does
is it hyperexcites the
phrenic nerve three
times in a row, a very unnatural
pattern for the phrenic nerve
to fire.
And then it undergoes
a hyperpolarization,
as we call it, in which
the phrenic nerve actually
stands a much lower probability
of getting activated again
for some period of
time afterwards.
So it is important
that you try and return
to normal cadence of breathing
after doing this three inhales
followed by a long exhale.
If you need to perform
it a second time in order
to eliminate hiccups because
they're simply not going away,
that's fine.
You can do that.
But as far as we
know, this is the most
efficient and science-supported
way to eliminate hiccups.
Now, up until now
I've been talking
about breathing techniques,
and I've mainly focused
on breathing techniques
that emphasize the exhale,
whether or not it's the
carbon dioxide tolerance
test, whether or not
it's cyclic sighing
or the physiological sigh
that you use in real time
to reduce stress.
One thing that we haven't
talked about so much
is cyclic hyperventilation.
Cyclic hyperventilation,
as you recall,
is a bout of 25 or
so breaths inhaling
deeply through the nose and then
passively exhaling or sometimes
actively exhaling,
typically through the mouth.
So it might look like this.
[HYPERVENTILATES] That's a very
active inhale through the nose
and exhale through the mouth.
It can also be
done active inhale
through the nose, passive exhale
through the mouth, like so.
[HYPERVENTILATING]
In any event, that pattern
of breathing repeated
for 10 to 25 breaths
greatly increases
levels of autonomic arousal.
In fact, it's known to deploy
adrenaline from the adrenals.
And in our study, we had people
then expel all their air,
so breathe out, hold their
breath for 15 to 30 seconds,
and then repeat for a
period of five minutes.
That did lead to some very
interesting and positive
physiological changes in
terms of stress mitigation,
although not as
significant as was
observed with cyclic sighing,
as I talked about earlier.
Now, there is a lot of interest
in cyclic hyperventilation
for sake of, for instance,
extending breath holds.
This has become popular in part
because of the so-called Wim
Hof method, which
is a method that
combines breathing,
cyclic hyperventilation,
followed by lungs full or
lungs empty breath holds,
depending on which variant
of the Wim Hof method one
is using.
Separately-- and I really
want to emphasize separately--
the Wim Hof method also
involves deliberate
cold exposure, which, as all
of you know, I'm a big fan of
and we've done episodes
of this podcast on.
And we have toolkits on
deliberate cold exposure
for increasing dopamine
levels, epinephrine levels,
immune system
function, et cetera.
Wim Hof method also
incorporates that.
And it has a
mindfulness component.
I do want to caution
people that any time you're
doing cyclic
hyperventilation, you
want to be very cautious about
not doing it in or near water
because it does greatly increase
the risk of shallow water
blackout.
And that's because when you
do cyclic hyperventilation,
you are expelling, you're
exhaling more carbon dioxide
than usual.
And what I haven't told you yet
is that the trigger to breathe
is actually an increase
in carbon dioxide.
What I mean by that is
you have a small set
of neurons in your
brainstem that
can detect when carbon dioxide
levels in your bloodstream
reach a certain level.
And when they reach that level,
they trigger the gasp reflex
and/or the hunger for breathing.
In other words, we don't
breathe because we crave oxygen,
although we do need oxygen,
of course, in order to survive
and for our brain to function
and our bodily organs
to function.
But our brain is wired such that
it has a threat sensor, which
is carbon dioxide levels
are getting too high,
and that's what triggers
the motor reflex to breathe
and to, in some
cases, gasp for air,
depending on how
starved for air we are.
So if you do cyclic
hyperventilation,
whether or not
it's Wim Hof method
or whether or not
it's Tummo method--
again, these things are similar.
They're not exactly the same.
There are other
breathing methods
that incorporate cyclic
hyperventilation.
What you're doing
is you're getting
rid of a lot of carbon
dioxide, and therefore, you're
removing the impulse
or lowering the impulse
to breathe so that when you
enter that breath hold phase
after the hyperventilation, it's
a much longer period of time
before you feel the
anxiety and the hunger
and the impulse to breathe.
That's one of the real
benefits of any technique that
incorporates cyclic
hyperventilation,
is that rather than reduce
your stress level in real time,
it actually does the opposite.
It increases your stress level.
It increases your levels
of autonomic arousal.
But you're doing
it deliberately.
And then during those breath
holds, what's happening
is you have a lot of
adrenaline circulating
in your system
because of the way
that hyperventilation triggers
the release of adrenaline
from your adrenal glands.
It also triggers the
release of epinephrine,
which is the same as
adrenaline, from a little brain
area called locus
coeruleus, which
makes you feel more alert.
And then during
those breath holds
and in the subsequent rounds
of cyclic hyperventilation,
people experience what it is
to have a lot of adrenaline
in their system.
But they are
controlling the release
of that adrenaline, which is
far and away different than when
life events are triggering
that adrenaline.
So what it really is is a
form of self-induced stress
inoculation.
And I do think
there are benefits
to practicing cyclic
hyperventilation because it
does allow you to learn how
to self-deploy adrenaline
and epinephrine
from locus coeruleus
and from the adrenals.
Or I got that
backwards-- adrenaline
from your adrenals
and epinephrine
from locus coeruleus.
And it allows you
to explore what
it is to maintain calm
state of mind and body
when you have a
lot of adrenaline
in your system, which
certain studies are starting
to show can allow people
to be able to lean
into the stressful
aspects of life.
And let's be honest, life
is stressful in any event.
And we're all going
to experience stress
at some point or another.
And when we do, we
want to make sure
that we're not overtaken by
the release of adrenaline
from the adrenals, that
sudden surge of epinephrine
from locus coeruleus.
So doing cyclic hyperventilation
maybe one or two
times per week-- again,
25 breaths, active inhale,
passive or active exhale.
Do expect to feel tingly because
of that reduction in carbon
dioxide from exhaling so much.
Do expect to feel a
little bit agitated.
Be very careful
doing this if you're
somebody who has anxiety
attacks or somebody who
has panic attacks or
disorders of any kind.
But if you don't and you
want to explore this,
you'll notice you start
to feel really ramped up.
And then during
the breath holds,
which, again, can be done
by exhaling and stopping
for some period of time,
15, maybe even 60 seconds,
is a time in which
you can explore
how to remain mentally calm.
Some people even choose
to do math problems
or think of things in a
kind of structured way
while they have a lot of these
hormone neurotransmitters
circulating at high levels in
their system, in other words,
as a way to learn to manage your
mind and body under conditions
of stress.
Now, if you are somebody who's
using deliberate cold exposure,
either cold showers or ice
baths or cold immersion,
I often get asked
how best to breathe
during those different
types of activities.
Really, there's no
best way to breathe.
Although if you wanted
to turn those activities
into their own form
of stress inoculation,
again, please don't use
cyclic hyperventilation.
That's dangerous.
I don't recommend it whatsoever.
But you can try to actively
slow your breathing, that is,
to make sure that you're
engaging in rhythmic breathing.
Now, up until now I've said
that rhythmic breathing is
the default.
Pre-Botzinger nucleus
controlling rhythmic
breathing is the default
and that doubling up
on inhales and exhales
is something that happens when
you deliberately take over
the action of
pre-Botzinger complex.
Now, that's true
99% of the time.
However, there are
certain conditions,
such as conditions of heightened
state of emotional arousal--
if you think about
somebody who's been crying,
oftentimes they'll
do the double inhale,
exhale [INHALES SHAKILY]
or triple inhales.
Or if somebody is very, very
afraid, it's all inhales.
So it does sometimes
happen spontaneously.
Actually, when we get
into very cold water,
there's a very robust
decrease in the activation
of the prefrontal
cortex, which is
the area of brain real estate
right behind the forehead
that controls structured
thinking, your ability
to reason and make sense
of what's going on.
If you get into
really cold water,
you should not expect that
brain region to work or at least
not work very well at all for
the first 20 or 30 seconds
that you're in the cold water.
From the time you
get into cold water,
because here we're talking
about deliberate cold exposure,
I encourage you to try
and control your breathing
and make it rhythmic, that is,
inhales follow exhales follow
inhales follow
exhales, even if they
have to be fast inhale
exhale, inhale, exhale.
Why?
Because the default when we get
into a stressful circumstance,
emotionally or physically
stressful circumstance,
is that rhythmic breathing stops
and that parafacial nucleus
takes over and it's
[INHALES RAPIDLY],,
and it's that kind
of panicky mode.
And by simply controlling
our breath, again,
even if it's fast
from inhale to exhale
and making sure that we're
alternating inhales and exhales
rhythmically-- and
what you'll find
is that you'll be
able to navigate
that what would otherwise be
a very stressful circumstance
and make it less stressful
or maybe even pleasant.
And that skill
definitely translates
to other aspects
of life in which
you're hit square in the face
with something stressful.
You'll notice your breathing
and your pattern of breathing
switching to multiple
inhales or breath holding,
essentially departing
from rhythmic breathing.
And by quickly returning
to rhythmic breathing
and maybe even trying
to slow the breathing
and extend those exhales,
you'll find that you
can very quickly calm down.
Next, I'd like to discuss what
I find to be an absolutely
fascinating topic.
It's also one that's highly
useful in the world, which
is how your specific
patterns of breathing
relate to your ability to learn
and to remember information,
how it can modulate fear,
and a number of other aspects
of how your brain functions.
This is a literature that's
been reviewed recently
in a lot of exquisite
detail in a beautiful review
by Jack Feldman, who
I mentioned earlier,
one of the pioneers of the
neuroscience of breathing.
The title of the review is
"Breathing Rhythm and Pattern
and Their Influence on Emotion."
Again we'll, provide a link
to this review in the show
note captions.
This review includes discussion
of several studies, one
in particular that I'll get
into in a bit of detail,
that describes the following.
Right now, I just want
you to breathe regularly,
meaning rhythmically.
You can inhale and
exhale through your mouth
or through your nose.
I'd prefer that you do
it through your nose
because nasal
breathing, unless you
need to breathe through your
mouth because of hard exercise
or eating or talking,
is always going
to be the better way to go.
Nasal breathing improves
the aesthetic of your face.
That's been shown.
We'll talk about that just
briefly in a few minutes.
Nasal breathing
improves the amount
of oxygen you can
bring into your system,
et cetera, et cetera.
OK, so just breathe.
Inhale, exhale, inhale, exhale.
And know that
during your exhales,
your pupil, that is, the pupil
of your eye, is getting bigger.
And as you exhale,
it's getting smaller.
In addition, when you inhale,
your reaction time to anything
that happens around you-- a
car swerving in front of you,
something that you might detect
in the periphery of your vision
or hear off in the distance--
increases significantly compared
to when you're exhaling.
In addition, when
you are inhaling,
your ability to remember
things, especially
things that take a bit
of effort to remember,
and your ability to
learn new information
is significantly greater than
it is when you're exhaling.
Now, as you hear all that,
you're probably thinking, OK,
how do I just inhale?
Well, of course, that's not
going to be the best approach.
You need to exhale as well
for all the reasons you now
are well aware of.
But what these findings
really illustrate--
and I should mention
these findings
are all carried out in humans.
So these relate to some
stuff in animal studies.
But what I just described has
been shown in human studies
consistently.
When we inhale
and, in particular,
when we inhale through
our nose, our brain
is not functioning in the
same way as when we exhale.
Now, that doesn't
mean that our brain
is functioning in a
deficient way when we exhale.
It just doesn't function
as well as it relates
to memory retrieval,
memory formation,
and some other
aspects of cognition.
Now, you might be asking, why
in the world would this be?
Well, I wasn't consulted
at the design phase,
and anyone that tells
you that they were you
should back away from quickly.
But one reasonable explanation
for why our brain functions
better, at least in the context
of what I just talked about,
when we inhale is because the
olfactory system is actually
the most ancient sensory system
of all the sensory systems we
have.
So before vision, before
audition, before touch,
before all of that,
the olfactory system
is the most ancient system.
And the olfactory
system, of course,
is designed to detect
chemicals in the environment.
And so if you imagine
an early organism
that perhaps we evolved
from or perhaps we
didn't but nonetheless
that we share
some features of, at least in
terms of olfactory function,
in order to get that chemical
information into the brain,
you need to inhale.
You need to bring
that information in.
Now, for aquatic animals, they
could take it in through water.
But for animals that are
terrestrial that live on land,
they would have to get
it through the air.
So inhalation, we know,
activates certain regions
of the so-called
piriformis cortex.
These are areas of the
neocortex that are more ancient,
as well as increasing
the activity of brain
areas such as the hippocampus,
which is a brain area involved
in learning and memory.
In fact, one of the studies
that illustrates this most
beautifully is a study
that was published
in The Journal of
Neuroscience in 2016.
By the way, Journal
of Neuroscience
is a very fine journal.
And the title of this paper
is "Nasal Respiration Entrains
Human Limbic Oscillations and
Modulates Cognitive Function."
This is a paper that followed
up on an earlier paper that
showed that when people
breathe in through their nose,
their recognition and
their discrimination
of different odors was far
greater than when they breathe
in through their mouth.
Now, that result
was interesting,
but it was also sort of a
duh because you smell things
with your nose, not your mouth.
You taste things
with your mouth,
and you speak with
your mouth, and there
are bunch of other things
you can do with your mouth.
But nonetheless, that
study pointed to the idea
that the brain is different
during nasal inhalations
versus nasal
exhalations versus mouth
inhalations versus exhalations.
What it basically showed
is that the brain ramps up
its levels of activity,
and that signal to noise
that we talked about
earlier, if you recall,
that ability for the
brain to detect things
in the environment, is
increased during inhalations.
But because that earlier study
focused on smell, on olfaction,
there was a bit of
a confound there.
It was hard to separate
out the variables.
So this paper, the one I just
mentioned, "Nasal Respiration
Entrains Human and Limbic
Oscillations and Modulates
Cognitive Function," did not
look at detection of odors.
Rather, it looked at things
like reaction time or fear.
And basically, what it found is
that reaction time is greatly
reduced when people
are inhaling.
So they had people look
at fearful stimuli.
They looked at their reaction
time to fearful stimuli,
in other words, their
ability to detect
certain kinds of stimuli.
And they were given a lot of
different kinds of stimuli.
So they had to be able to
discriminate between one
sort of-- oops, excuse me.
By the way, folks,
for those listening,
I just bumped the microphone,
getting rather animated here.
What the subjects
had to do was detect
one type of stimulus
versus another stimulus
that they were being exposed to.
And what they found is
if people were inhaling
as that fear-inducing stimulus
was presented, their reaction
time to notice it was
much, much faster.
And they related that to
patterns of brain activity,
and they were able to do that
because they were actually
recording from
the brain directly
from beneath the skull.
And they were able to
do that because they
had some patients that had
intracranial electrodes
embedded in their brain
for sake of trying
to detect epileptic seizures.
So there's a lot to
this study and a lot
that we could discuss.
But the basic takeaway is
that when people are inhaling,
that is, when
they're drawing air
in through their
nose in particular,
their ability to
detect what's going
on in the world
around them is greatly
enhanced and not just
for fear but also
for surprise of all sorts.
So when people are
inhaling, their ability
to detect novel stimuli,
things that are unexpected
or that are unusual
in their environment,
is significantly increased.
Again, we'll put a link
to this study as well.
I find it to be one of the
more interesting studies
in this realm, although there
are now many additional studies
that support this
statement that I
made earlier, which is
that during inhalation,
also called
inspiration, there are
a number of very fast
physiological changes,
such as changes
in pupil diameter,
changes in the activity
of the hippocampus,
this memory encoding and
retrieval area of the brain,
and other areas of the brain.
So what's the tool
takeaway from this?
If you are sitting down to read
or research or study or you
really want to learn
some information--
maybe you're listening to a
podcast or some other sorts
of information that
you want to retain--
it actually makes
sense to increase
the duration or the intensity
of your inhales as you do that.
The more that you're inhaling
relative to exhaling in terms
of duration, the more that
your brain is in this focused
mode and this mode of being
able to access and retrieve
information better.
Now, there's one
caveat to this that I
think is important because
I know a number of people
listen to this podcast
for sake of gleaning tools
not just for
cognitive enhancement
but for physical enhancement.
It turns out that when
you are inhaling air,
you're actually less
able or, I should say,
less efficient at generating
voluntary movements.
Now, that might
come as a surprise.
Up until now, we've basically
been talking about inhalation
is great, almost to the
point where you wonder like,
is the exhalation
good for anything?
You don't want to overbreathe
and kick out too much carbon
dioxide.
Well, of course exhalation
is great for things.
In fact, if you're somebody
that's played baseball
or softball, what are you told?
That you should
exhale on the swing
to generate the maximum
amount of power.
If you're somebody who has
done martial arts of any kind,
was traditional Western
boxing, as you strike,
that's where people
typically do the hiya,
laying the sort of
classic karate type thing.
That's more of a movie thing.
I don't know whether or not
people actually use the hiya.
But in boxing, oftentimes people
will do [EXHALES SHARPLY]..
They'll do a rapid exhalation,
a forceful exhalation,
keeping in mind, again, that
inhales typically are active.
They engage the
diaphragmatic muscle.
They engage those
intercostal muscles.
Whereas exhales
tend to be passive
unless we take active
control of the exhale.
And, indeed, our
ability to generate
fast, directed, so-called
volitional, voluntary movements
is greatly enhanced if we do
them during the exhale, not
the inhale.
Now, with all of that
said, I haven't yet
really talked about mouth
versus nasal breathing.
And it really can be a
fairly short discussion
because what abundant data now
show and has been beautifully
described in the book called
Jaws, A Hidden Epidemic--
this is a book that was written
by Paul Ehrlich and Sandra
Kahn, my colleagues at
Stanford School of Medicine.
It has an introduction and a
foreword from Jared Diamond
and from the great
Robert Sapolsky.
So some real heavy
hitters on this book.
What that book
really describes is
that whenever possible,
meaning unless you're
speaking or eating or you're
exercising or other activities
require some change in
your pattern of breathing,
we should really all be striving
to breathe through our nose,
not through our mouth.
And that relates
to the increased
resistance to breathing
through the nose
we talked about earlier.
Again, I'll say it a third
time, that increased resistance
through the nose allows you to
inflate your lungs more, not
less.
The other thing that
breathing through your nose
allows you to do is it both
warms and moisturizes the air
that you bring into
your lungs, which
is more favorable
for lung health
than breathing
through the mouth.
Hard breathing through
the mouth or simply
mouth breathing at all is
actually quite damaging
or can be, I should
say, quite damaging
to some of the respiratory
functions of your lungs.
That, of course, does not mean
that you shouldn't breathe hard
through your mouth when
you're running or sprinting
or exercising hard.
But you don't want
mouth breathing
to be the chronic default
pattern that you follow.
Nasal breathing is
the best pattern
of breathing to follow
as a default state.
Another aspect of
nasal breathing
that's really beneficial is
that the gas nitric oxide
is actually created
in the nasal passages.
It's a gas that can
cause relaxation
of the smooth muscles that
relate to the vasculature not
just of your nose
but of your brain
and for all the
tissues of your body.
This is why nasal breathing
and not mouth breathing
is great for when you want
to relieve congestion.
So a lot of these things
seem counterintuitive.
Your nose is stuffed.
So that mainly makes people
breathe through their mouth.
But it turns out that
breathing through your nose
will allow some dilation of the
vasculature, more blood flow,
dilation of the nasal passages,
and delivery of nitric oxide
to all the tissues of your body.
And that dilation of
the small capillaries
that innervate essentially
every organ of your body
allow the delivery
of more nutrients
and the removal of carbon
dioxide and other waste
products from those
tissues more readily
than if you're not
getting enough--
excuse me-- nitric
oxide into your system.
So a lot of reasons to
be a nasal breather.
If you want to check out that
book Jaws, A Hidden Epidemic,
it's a terrific read.
And it also shows some
absolutely striking pictures,
twin studies and so
forth, and some before
and afters of people and
the aesthetic changes
that they experienced when
they shifted from being a mouth
breather to a nose breather.
These are striking
examples that have been
observed over and over again.
When people mouth
breath, there's
an elongation of the jaw,
drooping of the eyelids,
and the entire jaw
structure really
changes in ways that are
not aesthetically favorable.
Fortunately, when people switch
to becoming nasal breathers--
and, of course, that
takes some encouragement
either by mouth taping or doing
their cardiovascular exercise
with mouth closed or by
doing the sorts of exercises
that we talked about earlier.
When they switch to becoming
nasal breathers by default,
the aesthetic changes that
occur are very dramatic
and very favorable,
including elevation
of the eyebrows, not
in an artificial sense
or in a kind of outrageous
way, but elevation
of the cheekbones,
sharpening of the jaw,
and, most notably, improvements
of the teeth and the entire jaw
structure.
In fact, one simple
test of whether or not
you can be an efficient
nasal breather
and whether or not you've been
nasal breathing efficiently
or most of the time in the
past or whether or not you've
been relying more on
mouth breathing that
was described in
the book Jaws is
you should be able
to close your mouth
and breathe only
through your nose.
Again, this is at rest, not
during exercise necessarily,
though you might do
it during exercise.
But close your mouth,
put your tongue,
on the roof of
your mouth, and it
should fit behind your teeth.
And you should be able to
nose breathe in that position.
Now, many people won't
be able to do that.
But fortunately, as
I mentioned earlier,
if you nasal breathe, that is,
you deliberately nasal breathe
when at rest for
some period of time,
you will experience an increased
ability to nasal breathe.
And you should also experience
some addition of space
within the palate of your
mouth to allow your tongue
to sit more completely on
the roof of your mouth.
This is especially
true for children
that perform this technique.
Again, I refer you to the
book Jaws, A Hidden Epidemic.
It's an absolutely
spectacular book.
You can also just look online
"before and after Jaws, Hidden
Epidemic" and look at
some of the changes
in facial structure
that occur when people
move from mouth to
nasal breathing,
and it's really quite striking.
So during today's
episode, per always, we
covered a lot of information.
First, we talked about
the mechanical aspects
of breathing-- the lungs, the
diaphragm, the trachea, and so
forth.
We also talked about the
chemical aspects of breathing,
that really breathing is
a way that we bring oxygen
to our cells and that we
get the correct levels
or, I should say, we maintain
the correct levels of carbon
dioxide in our system, neither
too much nor too little,
in order to allow
oxygen to do its magic
and to allow carbon
dioxide to do its magic.
Because as you learned
during today's episode,
carbon dioxide is not
just a waste byproduct.
It has very critical
physiological functions.
You need to have
enough of it around.
And therefore, you don't want
to overbreathe, especially
at rest.
We talked about
a tool to measure
how well you manage carbon
dioxide, the so-called carbon
dioxide tolerance test,
and various exercises
that you can use
simply by breathing
to decrease your
stress in real time,
decrease your stress
chronically around the clock.
Obviously, that's a good thing--
improve sleep, improve mood.
How to increase
breath hold times
and why you might
want to do that.
Also how to eliminate hiccups.
We talked about how
to breathe in order
to eliminate the
side stitch or side
cramp that you might
experience during exercise
and how to breathe in
order to improve learning
and memory, reaction time,
and various other aspects
of cognitive and
physical function.
I do realize it's a
lot of information.
But as always, I
try and give you
information that is clear,
hopefully interesting as well,
and actionable toward a
number of different endpoints.
So if you're somebody
that's just now starting
to think about the
application of breathwork,
I would encourage you to please,
yes, do that carbon dioxide
tolerance test.
That will give you some
window into how well
or how poorly you're
managing breathing.
And then here's the great news.
The great news is
that breathwork,
that is, deliberate
respiration practices,
are very effective at
creating change very quickly.
In some cases, such as the
use of the physiological sigh
or cyclic hyperventilation,
those changes
can be experienced the
first time and every time
because, again,
these are not hacks.
These are aspects of
your breathing apparati,
including the mechanical
stuff and the neural stuff
and the gas exchange stuff,
all of which you were born with
and that are available
to you at any moment.
So all you really have to do
is explore them and deploy them
as you feel necessary.
If you're learning from
and/or enjoying this podcast,
please subscribe to
our YouTube channel.
That's a terrific zero
cost way to support us.
In addition, please
subscribe to the podcast
on Spotify and Apple.
And on both Spotify
and Apple, you
can leave us up to
a five star review.
If you have questions
for us or comments
about the podcast
or guests that you'd
like me to include on
the Huberman Lab podcast,
please put those in the
comment section on YouTube.
I do read all the comments.
Please also check
out the sponsors
mentioned at the beginning and
throughout today's episode.
That's the best way to
support this podcast.
Not so much on today's episode,
but on many previous episodes
of the Huberman Lab podcast,
we discuss supplements.
While supplements aren't
necessary for everybody,
many people derive tremendous
benefit from them for things
like improving sleep, hormone
function, cognitive function,
and so on.
The Huberman Lab
podcast is now partnered
with Momentous supplements.
We've done that for
several reasons.
First of all,
Momentous supplements
are of the very highest quality.
Second of all,
Momentous supplements
tend to center around single
ingredient formulations.
This is incredibly important.
Because if you're going
to include supplements
in your daily
regimen, you're going
to want to use the
right supplements
in the right
dosages, and you want
to do that in the most
biologically and cost effective
way.
And single ingredient
formulations
are the only way that you
can determine what works
and what doesn't work
for you, and it's
the only way in which you can
adjust the dosage of given
supplements or maybe even
alternate days that you take
one and not the other in a
way that really allows you
to home in on which
supplements are going
to be ideal for your
mental health, physical
health, and performance.
Also, Momentous supplements
ship internationally.
And that's great because
we know a number of you
reside outside of
the United States.
If you'd like to see the
supplements discussed
on the Huberman Lab podcast,
you can go to live momentous,
spelled O-U-S, so
livemomentous.com/huberman.
If you're not already
following us on social media,
we are HubermanLab on
Instagram, Twitter, Facebook,
and LinkedIn.
And I should mention that
on all those platforms,
I discuss science and
science-related tools, some
of which overlap with the
contents of the Huberman Lab
podcast, but much of which
is distinct from the content
of the Huberman Lab podcast.
Again, it's HubermanLab on
all social media platforms.
And if you haven't already
subscribed to our Neural
Network newsletter, it is a
zero cost monthly newsletter
in which we give a summaries of
podcast episodes and toolkits--
for instance, toolkit
for sleep, toolkit
for managing dopamine, toolkit
for deliberate cold exposure.
Again, it's all zero
cost to sign up.
You simply go to
HubermanLab.com,
go to the Menu function,
scroll down to Newsletter,
and you supply your email.
We do not share your
email with anybody else.
And there are also some
example newsletters
there at HubermanLab.com
for you to explore.
Once again, I'd like to thank
you for today's discussion
all about the biology and
application of breathing.
And last but
certainly not least,
thank you for your
interest in science.
[MUSIC PLAYING]